herzlich willkommen zu zdf heute live
genf das ist ein klassischer gipfelort
hat viele berühmte gipfeltreffen schon
gesehen aber heute ist auch in genf eine
premiere es ist tatsächlich ein
historischer eine historische begegnung
denn zum ersten mal nach jahren großer
spannung zwischen washington und moskau
treffen sie sich heute zum ersten mal
der neue us präsident joe biden und
russlands präsident wladimir putin
zuletzt erinnerte das verhältnis ja doch
ein bisschen an kalten krieg insofern
die spannende frage heute ob beim
wirklichen face to face treffen bei
ihrem ersten wirklichen treffen zusammen
die beiden eine art draht finden der
eine basis sein könnte um eine
annäherung zu schaffen
oder kommt es doch zu einer
konfrontation denn es gibt ja doch viele
konflikte mit spannung blickt die welt
also heute nach genf und am mittag sah
die welt diese bilder dafür der
russische präsident putin vor weil er
für sein zuspätkommen berüchtigt ist
wollten die amerikaner dass er zuerst
eintrifft pünktlich war er da dann 15
minuten später der us präsident joe
biden auch er wird vom gastgeber dem
präsidenten die pamela der schweiz
begrüsst und betritt dann die villa
grosch und dann um 13 uhr 25 sieht die
welt diese szene der erste handshake der
erste handschlag zwischen joe biden und
wladimir putin innen drin in der
bibliothek dann der auftakt fotoshooting
fototermin beiden die beine locker
übereinandergeschlagen präsident putin
man kennt es von anderen gipfeln ein
bisschen breitbeinig und griesgrämig
aber das weiß man nicht das war für die
presse
als die türen dann sich geschlossen
haben sind natürlich die wirklichen
gespräche geführt worden vier bis fünf
stunden wurden angesetzt und keiner
wusste genau wie das ganze abgeht wie
lange es dauern würde es denn es gibt
natürlich
viele viele heikle themen zu besprechen
was dabei herausgekommen ist das wollen
wir ihnen zeigen
beide präsidenten haben eines gemein und
haben einen wunsch will abgleich gehabt
nämlich dass sie nicht gemeinsam vor die
presse treten
also finden zwei pressekonferenzen statt
einmal die von präsident putin einmal
die von joe wright und wir wissen nicht
ganz genau wann welche stattfindet wir
werden aber beide zeigen es gibt
informationen von unserer russland
korrespondentin die auch in genf vor der
villa steht das wohl mit der
pressekonferenz von putin zu zu rechnen
ist in kürze die werden wir dann live
zeigen sobald putin vor die mikrofone
tritt ein statement abgibt und
hoffentlich auch fragen der journalisten
beantworten wird
danach wollen wir natürlich auch in
absoluter länger ausführlich die
pressekonferenz des amerikanischen
präsidenten zeigen joe biden sollte
seine pressekonferenz parallel zu der
von putin beginnen keine sorge sie
verpassen nichts
wir schneiden oder zeichnen die
pressekonferenz von beiden einfach
direkt mit und können sie dann nach
liefern und werden sie auch in extension
besprechen
im moment sehen wir noch niemanden vor
die kameras vor die mikrofone treten im
moment haben wir nur das signal von
draußen vor der villa gans in genf
insofern verpassen wenn nichts wollen
die zeit aber nutzen und mit jemandem
sprechen der beide seiten sehr sehr sehr
gut kennt der die beziehungen zwischen
den usa und washington zwischen den usa
und moskau seit langem verfolgt nämlich
mit tyson barker von der gesellschaft
von der deutschen gesellschaft für
auswärtige politik ich grüße sie ganz
herzlich in berlin mit guten abend herr
berka prima dass sie die zeit haben es
ist ja doch ein besonderer tag heute
und wir warten gespannt auf die gipfel
ergebnisse kann man irgendwie sagen es
hat jetzt eine lange eiszeit gegeben und
vielleicht jeder tropfen der vor dem eis
schmilzt das wäre schon ein erfolg
also ich glaube dass es nicht das ziel
für dieses gibt verloben ehrlich zu sein
also die da er auf dem bild stand stand
annäherung oder konfrontation und ich
glaube für beide seite ist es weder noch
das ziel dieses gibt es ist eine neue
stabilität zu schaffen
die kommunikationslinien ein bisschen
berechenbare zu machen denn schließlich
geräten von den zwei großen klar machten
und in der kombination in dieser zeit
war die kommunikation schon relativ
unabschätzbare unberechenbar wir hatten
die kündigung von vielen verträgen die
enev vertrag zb den open skies vertrag
der das transparenz erschafft hat was
ihr nukleartechnologie nuklearwaffen
entwicklung und positionierung für
beiden seiten geschaffen hat und das
sorgt für eine sehr gefährliche
situation auf beiden seiten also ich
glaube wenn es ein ziel für die beiden
demonstrationen gibt und auch für die
himmel ist es berechenbare stabilität
strategische stabilität ohne
kommunikationslinien wieder einmal zu
schaffen
ok also schon mal eine ganz andere
einordnen ich habe eben gesagt berlin
fängt aber auch mit b an wo sie sind
nämlich in bratislava
insofern noch mal vielen dank dass sie
auch da im hotelzimmer zwischen
konferenzen die zeit gefunden haben um
mit uns diesen gipfel zu analysieren
das signal geht ja auch nach bratislava
können wir gemeinsam also die
pressekonferenz verfolgen
wir warten immer noch es tut sich noch
nichts aber beide seiten haben vor dem
gipfel schon gesagt es ist ein
besonderer gipfel aber er ist
ergebnisoffen jetzt verraten sie doch
mal so ein scanner was bedeutet das denn
in der diplomatensprache also das ist
erwartungsmanagement schlechthin also
das heißt sie wollen keine falsche
erwartungen stellen die nicht erreicht
werden und oder weil es ist schon
relativ bescheiden das was aus diesem
gipfel kommen kann also die beziehung
wie sie gesagt haben ist auf eine
eiszeit besonders durch diese häufige
grenze mehr attacken die die in den usa
zeiten stattgefunden hat erstmals auf
diesen castor auch im fleisch system
die sind wirklich es zeigt die die macht
der cyber attacken seines sicherheit
wird eine viel wichtigere thema hybride
kriege ist immer wichtiger und natürlich
das information haben wir erlebt in
unseren auch in unserem letzten wahl in
den usa 20 20 ich glaube fünf arbeiten
hat er auch nicht so viel spielraum den
im kongress des kongress auf beiden
seiten
beide parteien sind ziemlich russland
skeptisch haben schon paar kunden von
sanktionen durchgeführt inklusive auf
dem 2 das hat die beiden minister
verhängt und dann zurückgezogen oder
auch pause gesetzt weil er eben diese
diese offenheit schaffen möchte um diese
stabilität wieder mal zu schaffen aber
dass es zu einem durchbruch kommt das
ist etwas was weder washington noch
moskau erwartet dann wollen wir parallel
natürlich nicht den blick auf die villa
orange in genf verpassen wir haben immer
ein blick darauf was dort passiert
bisher ist wladimir putin noch nicht für
irgendein mikrofon getreten wir haben
aber ich war unsere korrespondenten dort
und die haben beobachtet dass der wagen
mit der amerikanischen flagge abgefahren
ist wir können die bilder vielleicht
gerade mal zeigen nämlich joe biden
das
ist die villa orange aus dem achtzehnten
jahrhundert direkt am genfer see samstag
daumen hoch signalisierte er aber das
verrät uns noch nicht ganz so viel über
die ergebnisse die wird so erwarten wir
die beiden dann in seiner
pressekonferenz uns metall die er eben
die ganzen dinge sieht einige minuten
dann wohl nach putin auf seine
pressekonferenz warten wir noch da muss
in ruhe die sonnenbrille aufgesetzt
werden und dann geht es wohl los das ist
der amerikanische präsident der wie
gesagt den treffpunkt den die villa la
crash in genf verlässt mit seiner
staatslimousine und der amerikanischen
flagge vorne
bis die erste pressekonferenz von
wladimir putin beginnt wollen wir eben
noch weiter reden mit ihnen theissen
barker es ist ja einigkeit gab es vor
dem gipfel zumindest in einem punkt
nämlich sie haben es schon gesagt es hat
viele sanktionen gegeben die das
verhältnis gerade in der letzten zeit
überschattet haben beide seiten haben
glasklar gesagt die beziehung sind auf
einem tiefpunkt der macht kein hehl
draus und putins sprecher dimitri peskow
sagte heute der staatsagentur tap noch
vor dem gipfel selbst in der zeit der
sowjetischen geschichte haben wir nie
einen solchen mangel an kontakten gehabt
diesen mangel an dialog gebe es nun vor
dem hintergrund eines wachsenden
konfliktpotenzials in der welt sie haben
es ja gerade gesagt da gibt es ja viele
knackpunkte syrien aus ukraine etc wie
ist es eigentlich dazu gekommen dass das
verhältnis sich so verschlechtert hat
was sind die knackpunkte was sind auch
vielleicht ereignisse die den werdegang
dieser beziehung beeinflusst haben wir
haben eine kleine chronologie die wir
uns gemeinsam anschauen
landhaus idylle am genfer see draußen
hochsommerliches ambiente drinnen hoffen
sie auf politisches tauwetter joe biden
und wladimir putin wollen nach
verbalattacken und politischen muskeln
spielen jetzt von angesicht zu angesicht
abklopfen wo ihre roten linien geben
kurz nachdem russland im märz 80.000
soldaten an die ukrainische grenze
verlegt und der us außenminister erneut
amerikas beistand im kampf für
demokratie garantiert als die spannung
zu eskalieren droht einigen sich beiden
und putin auf ein persönliches treffen
um strategische stabilität soll es gehen
nach jahren zunehmender konflikte um
gemeinsame leitplanken für einen
diplomatischen neuanfang 2013 war das
jahr in dem die bereits abgekühlten
russisch amerikanischen beziehungen
frostig wurden russland hatte gerade
adwords noten asyl gewährt als in kiew
die meisten proteste ausbrechen für
russland das werk amerikanische agenten
und auslöser für die politische eiszeit
2014 provoziert die annexion der krim
eine spirale aus sanktionen und boykott
russland wird aus dem kreis der g8
ausgeschlossen und das land
international zunehmend isoliert
2015 greift russlands luftwaffe aktiv in
den syrischen bürgerkrieg ein ein
weiterer stellvertreter krieg der das
verhältnis belastet während beide länder
noch gemeinsam den atomdeal mit iran
verhandeln 2016 eskaliert die lage als
russland die syrische offensive auf ein
apple unterstützt die amerikaner brechen
die friedensverhandlungen ab und
russland reagiert mit der kündigung von
verträgen zur nuklearen abrüstung als
donald trump die wahl um das us
präsidentenamt gewinnt sind die
beziehungen bereits an einem tiefpunkt
russlands einflussnahme auf die wahl und
die cyber-attacken zeigen schonungslos
schwachstellen im politischen system der
usa
2017 wird es zunächst so als würden sich
die usa unter präsident trump ernsthaft
um gespräche bemühen
doch die anhaltenden konflikte in der
ukraine in syrien und mit iran
verschärfen die spannungen weiter
diplomaten werden ausgewiesen geplante
öl abkommen scheitern 2018 wird der
ehemalige russische agent sergej skripal
mit naughty dog vergiftet die konflikt
spirale dreht sich weiter wieder
sanktionen und die ausweisung weiterer
diplomaten als donald trump beim treffen
mit putin in helsinki die eigenen
geheimdienstberichte zu russlands wahl
einmischung kleinredet steht putin als
politischer sieger da
eine reaktion lässt nicht lange auf sich
warten 2009/10 verhängt die usa
sanktionen gegen russische unternehmen
die am bau der pipeline nord stream 2
beteiligt sind 2020 überschatten
russische cyberangriffe das
amerikanische superwahljahr
nach der vergiftung des kreml kritikers
alexej nawalny nutzt russland amerika
solidarität als rechtfertigung um die
opposition im eigenen land
einzuschüchtern proteste angeblich
gesteuert von westlichen agenten ein
muster das sich auch in belarus
wiederholt
als joe biden kurz vor dem gipfel erneut
gefragt wird ob er wladimir putin für
einen killer halte dementiert der us
präsidenten nicht
und putin lächelt die verbalattacken weg
beide kennen sich beide spielen ihre
rollen
das treffen in genf ist ein gipfel der
selbstvergewisserung ein ausloten wie
weit der andere wohl gehen das zeigt die
spannungen die hier in der luft zu
spüren ist warum man gebannt auf genf
blickte joe biden hat vor dem treffen
gesagt ich werde präsident putin zu
verstehen geben dass es bereiche gibt in
denen wir zusammenarbeiten können wenn
er sich dafür entscheidet und in den
bereichen in denen wir nicht
übereinstimmen klar machen was die roten
linien sind
heissenberger was sind denn diese roten
linien die beiden jetzt wohl heute
nachmittag versucht hat putin
aufzuzeigen
ja ich glaube es gibt ein paar ein paar
gebiete wo er rote linien oder so klare
definitionen von eskalationen zeigen
möchte das eine ist eben cyberattacken
und ranzen packen die den schutz von
cyberkriminellen und ihre beziehungen
zur russischen star dass wenn es solche
attacken gibt dann wird es harte
gegenmaßnahmen geben und wird das schiff
erscheinen jetzt versuchen das ein
bisschen mehr zu definieren um damit
hoffentlich zu ermöglichen das zu einer
deeskalation von dieser arten retten
tacken kommt das zweite ist im bereich
attentatsversuche oder festnahme
versuche an oppositionsführer
zivilgesellschaft an medien sowohl im
land wo es natürlich als land seit
langem gegeben hat in russland in
weißrussland aber auch im ausland das
ist wichtig weil wir sehen dass die
russen der russische staat wird immer
dreister in ihre aktionen wie es
attentaten durchführt auf nato
territorium wir haben das in
großbritannien gesehen wir haben das in
deutschland natürlich gesehen und in
letzter zeit die unterstützung russlands
für diese flugzeug in führung und die
wo man protestiert das ist auch ein
punkt zwei weitere punkte die auch wir
also die usa und russland
kommunikationslinien auch machen müssen
sind erstmals im weltraum wir würden es
in den kommenden fünf jahren zählen dass
es mehr satelliten gibt mehr
wirtschaftliche nutzung vom weltraum
gibt im bereich internet im bereich
kommunikation mobilität etc
und wir wollen es versichern dass es
nicht zu einer destabilisierung oder
militarisierung des weltraums kommt und
das vierte was ich hier erwähnen würde
ist auch im polarkreis dann das ist auch
ein territorium entspannungs territorium
gebiet hilfe die usa und russland die
zwei muss man sagen große palaver mächte
und die definition die regeln dort sind
auch nicht so gut definiert bisher also
das sind neue gebiete wo die wirklich
die kommunikationsinfrastruktur schaffen
müssen um stabilität mittelfristig zu
schaffen
also da haben wir kritische punkte die
zu besprechen sind jetzt sehen wir
gerade live bilder die den russischen
präsidenten zeigen wie er die villa la
crash verlässt wir sehen ihnen da links
jetzt fasst er sich ganz kurz an der
oder salutiert und wird nach links
geleitet
wir können jetzt annehmen dass insofern
ja klar das gespräch beendet ist
ganz genau vorhersagen können wir jetzt
nicht wann die pressekonferenzen
beginnen die von beiden soll aber etwa
drei minuten nach putins rede beginnen
hier sehen wir einfach noch mal im
hintergrund die villa la groß und hier
vorbereitet ein pult mit der
amerikanischen flagge
da dürfte daneben wohl joe biden sein
und herren so ich stehe unterricht wir
hören zu ich denke es ist nicht
notwendig hier im einleitenden worte zu
sprechen ich denke das thema ist allen
bekannt dass es die strategische
stabilität dass es die sicherheit
das sind regionale konflikte
handelsbeziehungen ja wir haben noch
über die zusammenarbeit in der arktis
gesprochen so dass es ungefähr das
konglomerat der themen bitteschön guten
abend welche themen haben sie ja
besonders besprochen
das ukrainische thema wurde denn der don
was besprochen die situation dort wurde
dann gesprochen dass die das thema des
nato beitritts der ukraine besprochen
herr jakob hat wochen gab es denn
irgendwelche beschlüsse wie verliefen
die verhandlungen ja was die botschafter
anbelangt damit sie wieder vor ort tätig
sind nach moskau die rückkehr des
amerikanischen botschafters und des
russischen in die usa nach washington
ja da haben wir eine übereinkunft
getroffen sie werden wieder zurückkehren
das sind rein technische fragen
dann haben wir noch besprochen dass das
russische außenministerium und das state
department
die konsultationen aufnimmt auf
diplomatische es gibt sehr viele offene
fragen die sich angehäuft haben und
beide seiten die amerikanische seite
insbesondere ist lösungsorientiert ja
und die ukraine ja die wurde auch
angesprochen das team wurde angesprochen
nicht sehr detailliert aber soweit ich
den beiden verstanden habe ist er damit
einverstanden dass die grundlage zur
regulierung des der ukraine das minsker
abkommen ist und was den möglichen
nato-beitritt der ukraine das wurde hier
nur
stichpunktartig angesprochen
ungefähr so itar tass bitteschön
sie haben gesagt herr präsident dass die
strategische stabilität eines der
besprochenen themen war und welche
entscheidungen gab es hier wird denn
russland und wären die usa hier die
verhandlungen wieder aufnehmen zur
strategischen stabilität und der
abrüstung und insbesondere in bezug auf
das start abkommen wird es verhandlungen
geben zur verlängerung des abkommens
werden die parameter neu bewertet oder
wird hier ein neues abkommen getroffen
sowohl bei den usa als auch bei russland
liegt eine sehr besondere verantwortung
im hinblick auf die strategische
stabilität und sicherheit in der welt
weil wir sowohl auch im hinblick auf die
mengen als auch auf die qualität und die
modernität unserer nuklearwaffen hier
führend sind
wir tragen diese verantwortung und sind
uns dieser verantwortung bewusst und er
präsident biden hat hier die richtige
entscheidung getroffen bis 2024 das
start-abkommen und zu verlängern
natürlich steht die frage offen was wie
geht es weiter
wir haben darüber gesprochen dass wir
die konsultationen zwischen zwischen dem
russischen außenministerium und dem
state department aufnehmen
ja unsere kollegen werden dann darüber
sprechen wer die delegation leitet wer
werden delegation eingehend und wann
die verhandlungen aufgenommen werden
könnten sie bitte die dynamik zwischen
ihnen und präsident bei den aufnahmen
second war das freundschaftlich oder
haben sie zugegeben dass sie die
ukrainische sicherheit nicht mehr betont
werden und dass sie auch die opposition
in russland nicht mehr unterdrücken
werden also was der allgemeine eindruck
war
ich denke es gab hier keine
feindseligkeit unser treffen verlief
natürlich in einem prinzipiellen rahmen
vier haben unterschiedliche standpunkte
in bezug auf eine reihe von fragen aber
wir haben gesehen dass wir von beiden
seiten den willen gesehen haben einander
zu verstehen und mögliche wege
aufzuzeigen wie wir unsere positionen
zueinander führen können wir haben ein
sehr konstruktives gespräch geführt und
was die cyber sicherheit angeht so haben
wir eine übereinkunft getroffen dass wir
hier konsultationen aufnehmen werden ich
denke das ist sehr wichtig und jetzt in
bezug darauf wer welche verpflichtungen
eingehen muss ich möchte sie darüber
informieren dass es bestimmte es gibt es
gibt tatsachen die bekannt sind aber
vielleicht nicht allen daher dass kopf
wird das ihnen später sagen aus
amerikanischen quellen folgt dass die
größte anzahl der cyber attacken in der
welt aus dem cyber raum der usa folgt an
zweiter stelle
kanada
dann gefolgt von zwei
lateinamerikanischen staaten dann und
russland ist nicht in dieser liste als
land von dem diese cyber attacken
ausgehen dann 2020 haben wir ja wir
haben von den usa eine während zehn
anfragen bekommen bezüglich der cyber
attacken auf us amerikanische
einrichtungen
wie unsere kollegen sagen aus dem cyber
raum russlands und dieses jahr waren es
zwei anfragen sowohl die letztjährigen
anfragen als auch die diesjährigen
anfragen wurden von uns umfänglich
beantwortet wir haben an die
entsprechende behörde in den usa letztes
jahr 45 solcher anfragen gerichtet und
dieses jahr über 30 und keine einzige
wurde beantwortet das zeugt davon dass
wir das hier noch sehr viel gearbeitet
werden muss und wer wann welche
verantwortung übernehmen muss
das stellt sich während der
verhandlungen heraus wir waren uns im
klaren dass diese verhandlungen
aufgenommen werden müssen und wir finden
dass die cyber-sicherheit heute in der
ganzen welt äußerst wichtig ist sowohl
für die usa insbesondere als auch für
russland wir kennen das aus den cyber
attacken auf das unternehmen der
leitungen der enisa
wir haben wir wissen auch dass dieses
unternehmen 5 millionen lösegeld gezahlt
hat ein teil dieses geldes wurde bereits
aus den elektronischen börsen zurück
erstattet aber ein anderer teil nicht
was hat das mit russland zu tun
ja wir sind konfrontiert mit denselben
bedrohungen insbesondere auf das
gesundheitssystem eines großen einer
großen region der russischen föderation
und wir sehen diese attacken
wir sehen dass diese attacken diese
angriffe aus dem amerikanischen
cyberraum koordiniert werden ich denke
nicht dass die us amerikanischen
behörden darin interessiert sind man
sollte diese gedanken diese
beschuldigungen zurück vergessen und auf
expertenebene sich zusammensetzen und
das besprechen
auf der ebene der usa und der russischen
föderation und darin haben wir eine
übereinkunft getroffen und wir sind dazu
bereit
haben sie in diesem meeting zugegeben
dass sie haben sich dazu kommt dass sie
die ukraine nicht betonen werden und der
zweite oder dritte teil haben sie auch
gesagt dass sie die opposition innerhalb
russlands nicht mehr unterdrücken will
diesen teil habe ich nicht gehört
vielleicht wurde sie nicht übersetzt
oder vielleicht wollten sie jetzt eine
zweite frage stellen was die ukraine
anbelangt wir haben nur eine
verpflichtung
wir müssen das minsker abkommen
unterstützen und die umsetzung darin
unterstützen wir und wenn die
ukrainische seite wird so bereitet dann
werden wir das auch unterstützen und ich
möchte in ihre aufmerksamkeit darauf
lenken dass im november letzten jahres
nicht
die ukrainische delegation ihre
vorstellung dargelegt hat wie sie das
minsker abkommen umsetzen wollen zehn
sich das dokument an dass es nicht
verschlüsselt in erster linie muss man
ein vorschlag aufzeigen wie der donbass
integriert wird in die verfassung dazu
muss man das muss man die verfassung an
sich ändern so steht das in dem abkommen
und das zweite die grenze zwischen
russland und der ukraine entlang der don
was linie erst dann durch die
ukrainischen grenzkontrollen
kontrolliert wird wenn die wahlen am
nächsten tag nach den wahlen die ukraine
haben vorgeschlagen dass man zuerst die
grenzkontrollen zurückschickt an die
grenze und erst dann das andere umsetzt
das bedeutet dass die ukrainischen
streitkräfte von bass beschreiten dann
haben sie vorgeschlagen die grenze
zwischen der ukraine und russland in
diesem bereich zu schließen und drittens
die wahlen erst drei monate nach der
erfüllung dieser beiden schritte
durchzuführen
man muss kein jura studiert haben man
muss kein experte sein um zu verstehen
dass das nichts mit dem minsker abkommen
zu tun hat dass das dem minsker abkommen
einfach wieder spricht und welche
verpflichtungen kann hier russland auf
sich nehmen
ich denke die antwort ist klar und was
die übungen anbelangt wir führen übungen
auf unserem gebiet durch und sowie dass
die usa auch machen aber wir führen
keine übungen an den grenzen der us
amerikanischen grenzen durch aber unsere
amerikanischen partner machen dass
deswegen sollte nicht die amerikanische
seite besorgt sein sondern die russische
aber das ist auch gegenstand unserer
gespräche
und die klarstellung der standpunkt was
unserer unserer nicht systemischer
opposition anbelangt und der person die
sie genannt haben
diese person wusste dass er sie die
geltende gesetzgebung in russland
verletzt er musste sich zweimal melden
und er hat dass er hat russland
verlassen hat diesen beschluss ignoriert
er ist zur behandlung ins ausland
gefahren
dann kam er aus der behandlung raus aus
dem krankenhaus hat seine hat seine
sicht der dinge im internet
veröffentlicht er wurde dann aber es
wurde nach ihm gefahndet
er kam dann zurück und er hat diesen
schritt bewusst gemacht um verhaftet zu
werden er hat das gemacht was er wollte
worüber können welcher sprechen und was
dies ist nicht die systemische position
anbelangt ja diese pressekonferenz
erlaubt es uns nicht im detail darüber
zu sprechen aber ich möchte folgendes
sagen ich werde hier nicht schwieriges
sagen das wird klar sein wenn sie das
objektiv an ihre zuhörer und zuschauer
tragen können wäre ich ihnen sehr
dankbar
die usa haben russland als ihren feind
zu ihrem feind erklärt der kongress hat
das 2007 geschlossen in denen gesetzen
der usa steht demokratischen grundfesten
in unserem land unterstützen müssen und
die demokratischen
ja wenn russland und die demokratischen
organisationen
wenn russland ein feind ist welche
organisationen werden die usa in unserem
land unterstützen
ich denke nicht dass die organisation
die unser land unterstützen sondern die
die unser land eindämmen
die organisation und die menschen die
dazu beitragen die politik der usa in
russland zu beeinflussen
sollen wir uns hier verhalten ich denke
das ist klar
wir sollten hier besorgt sein aber wir
werden nur im rahmen des russischen
gesetzes handeln
dieses thema möchte ich fortsetzen
wir sind nun zeugen dass seitens der
amerikanischen seite die rhetorik der
politischen gefangenen aufgenommen wird
wurde das thema navalny im zuge ihrer
konsultationen und mit beiden irgendwie
angesprochen wenn ja wie und wir machen
zeugen einer neuen einer neuen
entwicklung
das wurde sehr grob über sie
angesprochen hat die menschenrechte das
thema der menschenrechte angesprochen
und der personen die diese themen in der
russischen föderation vertreten ja wir
haben auf seine initiative hin
gesprochen und was die aussagen betrifft
ja wir kennen sie alle präsident biden
hat mich danach angerufen wir haben uns
erklärt mich ich habe das akzeptiert
er hat mir vorgeschlagen und zu treffen
das war ja seine initiative wir haben
uns jetzt getroffen und das gespräch war
sehr konstruktiv ich habe nochmals
erfahren und gesehen dass er sehr
erfahren ist das präsent beiden sehr
erfahren ist wären fast zwei stunden
gesprochen nicht mit allen staatschefs
können wir so detailliert sprechen was
diese anschuldigungen betrifft so hat er
sein vorgänger ist von dieser ist diese
frage ausgewichen
aber wir sind bei den hat eine andere
antwort gewählt als präsent wissen sie
ich im prinzip alles was in unseren
ländern passiert dafür trägt die
verantwortung die politische führung und
die ersten personen werde
wer der mörder ist wer schuld ist auf
den straßen der usa wird jeden tag
jemand getötet
man sagt irgendwas und dann wird schon
gleich geschossen entweder auf die brust
oder in den rücken
eine frau hat ist aus dem auto gestiegen
ist weggelaufen sie wurde erschossen
das sind verbrechen aber afghanistan mit
einem schlag auf einen schlag werden 120
personen umgebracht ganze hochzeiten
nehmen wir an dass das ein fehler ist
aber wohnen oder aus helikoptern von
zivilen personen im irak was ist
wer ist dafür verantwortlich wer ist der
mörder
aber was oder was die menschenrechte
betrifft guantanamo funktioniert nach
wie vor das entspricht
nichts weder dem internationalen recht
nach dem us amerikanischen recht aber
guantanamo existiert gefängnisse wo
menschen gefoltert werden sind dass
menschenrechte
obwohl kaum einer wird in diesem raum
sagen dass das die einhaltung der
menschenrechte ist das ist die praxis
und ausgehend aus dieser praxis sehen
wir und wissen dass das dass es so etwas
gibt dass so etwas existiert und daraus
machen wir auch daraus machen wir auch
unsere schlussfolgerungen insbesondere
im hinblick auf die personen die geld
aus dem ausland bekommen
sie haben gesagt dass sie darüber
gesprochen haben die usa behauptet dass
russland die arktis interessiert und wir
haben von davon
us-außenminister blinken gehört was
wurde darüber gesprochen ja wir haben
dieses thema im großen format besprochen
das thema sehr detailliert und das ist
wichtig denke dass die arktis und die
nordroute sehr wichtig ist für die
wirtschaft vieler länder und nicht nur
regional gesehen und die sorgen der us
amerikanischen seite haben keinerlei
grundlage
wir unternehmen nichts was es nicht zur
zeit der udssr gab
wir stellen nur wieder die infrastruktur
her
die einst untergegangen ist ja wohl die
grenzen
auch die umwelt es wird dort eine
station aufgebaut
für den katastrophenschutz um einen
menschen zu retten oder für den
umweltschutz
ja ich habe meinen kollegen unseren
kollegen gesagt dass ich hier keinerlei
grund zur sorge sehen
nein im gegensatz ich denke wir müssen
hier zusammenarbeit wir müssen hier
zusammenarbeit
russland und die usa wir sind ja im
arktischen rat vertreten und die usa
auch acht länder insgesamt und russland
hat den vorsitz und zwischen alaska und
jk gibt es ja eine meeresstraße von der
einen seite sind die usa von anderen
seite russland und das sollte uns dazu
anstoßen unsere schultern
zusammenzuschließen und der wird durch
internationales recht geklärt
das ist die konvention von 1982 und
glaube ich und der polar cordex
bestehend aus verschiedenen dokumenten
2017 ratifiziert ich habe unseren
partnern er sagt dass wir russland in
vollem umfang vorhaben diese
internationalen normen zu achten
wir haben niemals
diese normen verletzt wir sind bereit
allen interessierten staaten unsere
hilfe anzubieten und den unternehmen
auch jetzt gibt es diese verbindung
sechs monate lang das klima ändert sich
dann wird es diese verbindung das ganze
jahr lang geben und unsere eisbrecher
sind hier die stärksten und ich möchte
sagen dass die konvention für
internationale seewege den rechts codecs
und dass die rechtsordnung und klärt was
ihnen mehrere anbelangt was territorial
mehrere anbelangt angrenzende was die
wirtschaftszonen angeht und die offene
see der binnen das binnenmeer das sind
die seen innerhalb des landes
territorialen gewässer zwölf seemeilen
weitere zwölf seemeilen sind die
angrenzenden gewässern und hier müssen
die staaten auch den seeweg ermöglichen
für zivile aber auch für militärische
hilfe gewähren was die ihnen mehrere
anbelangt die brillen mehrere so müssen
wir hier nichts gewähren aber diese
gebiete dieser binnenmeeres ja wenn ich
mich recht daran erinnere dass es obst
dann lsk mehr busen ja es gibt insgesamt
59 wir das so die länge das sind fast
1000 seemeilen ich denke ja so ungefähr
960 das ist unser souveränes recht die
schiffe passieren zu lassen oder nicht
aber wir wir hatten letztes jahr 1000
anträge
ja und das waren im prinzip russisch das
waren schiffe unter russische fahne die
von unseren behörden dem polar kollegs
entsprochen haben und der polar trax
legt fest
die anforderungen an verschiedenen
technischen ausrüstungen und schiffe
wenn wir alle diese länder daran
interessiert sind insbesondere die
mitgliedsstaaten des arktischen rates ja
es gibt natürlich fragen die zusätzlich
erörtert werden müssen aber wir werden
alle fragen lösen können ich sehe kein
einziges problem dass wir nicht lösen
könnten
die beziehungen zwischen den usa gute
beziehungen zwischen den usa und in
russland
das war der unterstand für gute ruhige
und sichere lage in der welt sie sagen
ja es gab eine gewisse warmherzigkeit in
dem gespräch vor dem treffen haben sie
über die roten linien gesprochen die uhr
die amerikaner haben natürlich auch ihre
roten linie konnten sie bei diesen
treffen eine übereinkunft treffen dass
man die roten linie
dass man die roten linien nicht
überschreitet um unsere beziehungen zu
stabilisieren im prinzip ist es uns klar
worüber unsere amerikanischen partner
sprechen im prinzip verstehen wir
worüber wir sprechen wenn es um die
roten linien geht aber so detailliert
haben wir die akzente oder etwas teilen
das konnten wir nicht aber wir haben
vereinbart dass wir im bereich der cyber
sicherheit zusammen arbeiten werden im
rahmen der konsultationen und im rahmen
der zusammenarbeit in der arktis und das
wird alles gegenstand unserer
besprechungen und ist ordentlich unsere
übereinkünfte seien sie bisher news
unsere amerikanischen kollegen bitte
vielen dank
präsident der antworten würden wenn
diese buttons auf bus und nicht stoppen
können
ich bin gespannt hatte etwas untergeht
rot oder die liste ihre opponenten die
tot sind oder in haft sind ist sehr
lange euro für freie wahlen
aber sie haben jetzt alle unterbunden
die möglich die möglich mögliche
präsidentschafts kandidaten werden
können was denken sie darüber was halten
sie davon
ich möchte nochmals wiederholen was die
ausländischen agenten die sogenannten
ausländischen agenten anbelangt und in
bezug auf die personen die sich
positionieren als nicht systemische
oppositionelle ich denke ja ich habe
bereits cnn geantwortet aber das sind
anscheinend die gesetze ihres chance
dass man auch ihre antwort ihre frage
beantworten muss gut ich werde das
nochmals beantworten
es wurde ein gesetz gesetz verabschiedet
das die usa bestimmte politische
organisation in russland unterstützen
werden gleichzeitig wurde russland als
feind klassifiziert und das wurde
öffentlich verlautbarte dass man
russland eindämmen wird die frage von
meiner seite welche organisationen
werden die usa unterstützt sie werden
auch bezahlt natürlich werden wir wie
auch die us-amerikaner in den 30er
jahren diese organisation ausländische
organisationen klassifizieren die arbeit
ist nicht unterbunden die tätigkeit ist
nicht verboten aber wenn die
organisation extremistische ausrichtung
hat dann ist das eine und diese
organisation die sie genannt haben
die hat öffentlich zu protesten
aufgerufen zu massenunruhen auch unter
und öffentlich dazu aufgerufen
molotowcocktails gegen die polizisten zu
nutzen
amerika hat vor kurzem die schwierigsten
konfrontationen innenpolitischen
konfrontationen
gehabt und auch die bewegung black lifes
matter ich werde das jetzt nicht
kommentieren aber das was wir gesehen
haben
die pogrome die gesetzesverletzungen die
us amerikaner tun uns leid aber wir
wollen ihm nicht dass das auf unserem
gebiet auf unserem in unserem land
passiert und wir werden alles
unternehmen um das zu unterbinden und
hier sollte man keine angst haben
bitte das mikrofon vergiftet sind oder
in haft sind bedeutet das nicht dass sie
keine fairen politischen kampf haben
wollen
ja wer getötet wird oder wer verhaftet
wird mit politischen forderungen sind
die menschen in den us-kongress
eingedrungen
400 von ihnen wurden angeklagt
es droht ihnen eine haft von bis zu 20
oder sogar bis zu 25 jahren sie werden
als terroristen bezeichnet
70 wurden sofort inhaftiert und 30 von
ihnen sind nach wie vor in haft auf
welcher grundlage ist immer noch unklar
von den offiziellen behörden werden wir
ja nicht informiert dritte insofern eine
teilnehmerin ist eine wurde vor ort
getötet von einem polizisten sie keine
bedrohung darstellte in vielen ländern
passiert dasselbe wie in unserem land
und ich möchte nochmals unterstreichen
wir teilen die sorge was in den usa
wird und es tut uns leid aber wir wollen
nicht zulassen dass dasselbe in unserem
land passiert ja noch ein paar fragen
denn das programm des präsidenten geht
dann weiter konnten sie mit den us
amerikanern eine übereinkunft treffen
über die rückkehr von russischen
staatsbürgern aus der amerikanischen
haft ja herr beiden präsident biden hat
diese frage aufgeworfen
in bezug auf us amerikanische bürger in
russischer haft wir haben diese frage
angesprochen man kann hier bestimmte
kompromisse finden und das russische
außenministerium und das state
department wird in diese richtung
zusammenarbeit
russland in russland den handel das ist
wahrscheinlich die positive agenda
die sein kann denn das geschäft beider
länder in der weiteren entwicklung
interessiert welche perspektiven sehen
sich hier das hängt nicht von uns ab das
hängt von der amerikanischen seite ab
wenn denn wir haben hier keinerlei
eingrenzt begrenzungen eingeführt als
wirtschaftlicher durch die usa
eingeführt wurden
die usa mehr verloren als russland ja
das hat natürlich unsere entwicklung
unsere entwicklung beeinflusst die usa
hat in dieser hinsicht die eindämmung
die aufgabe zur eindämmung russlands in
gewisser hinsicht erfüllt aber das ist
das eine
wir haben die größte delegation
petersburger wirtschaftsforum
die us delegation mit über 200
teilnehmern mussten mit
mussten die russische wirtschaft
verlassen mussten die verluste verlust
der einbussen und haben ihr geschäft an
ihre wettbewerber verläuft unser
handelsumsatz 28 us-dollar
aber wir haben jetzt im ersten quartal
ein wachstum von 16 prozent verzeichnet
wenn das so weitergeht dann werden beide
seiten davon also werden von der einen
seite drei wagen und von der bitteschön
die dame hier vorne
sie wird jetzt einheiten ermöglichen
gehört diese fragen zu stellen vor ein
paar jahren beiden getroffen als er noch
vize präsident war und er hat gesagt
dass er ihnen in die augen gesehen hat
und er hat dort keine seele
ich denke und es sie hätten darauf
geantwortet also verstehen wir uns haben
sie ihm in die augen geblickt und was
haben sie in seinen augen gesehen haben
sie haben jemanden gesehen mit dem sie
zusammenarbeiten können
und noch etwas hat er sie denn das so
eingeladen das weiße haus zu besuchen ja
oder nein und wenn ja
haben sie ja gesagt herr beiden hat mich
noch nicht eingeladen ins weiße haus zu
kommen ich habe eine derartige einladung
aus ähnlich ausgesprochen
ich denke dass die bedingungen dazu erst
aus reifen müssen ja was die seele
betrifft dort etwas zu sehen oder nicht
zu sehen wissen sie ich höre das nicht
zum ersten mal ehrlich gesagt ich kann
mich an ein solches gespräch nicht
entsinnen aber ich lasse es zu
es ist anscheinend meine aufmerksamkeit
entwichen aber wenn sie mich fragen
würden wie ich den partner einschätzen
geschäfts diesen gesprächspartner
einschätze präsent beiden sehr
konstruktiv sehr ausgewogen sehr
erfahren ja das sieht man sofort so wie
ich es auch erwartet habe er erinnerte
sich an
er sprach seine familie an vorüber seine
mutter sich mit ihm unterhalten hat das
hat vielleicht keinen direkten bezug zu
diesem treffen
aber das zeigt das niveau oder sagen wir
mal die das unterstreicht die qualitäten
seiner moralischen werte das ist sehr
attraktiv und wir haben eine sprache
gesprochen und das bedeutet nicht dass
wir gleich in die seele blicken müssen
in die augen und uns ewige liebe und
freundschaft spüren müssen nein
vertreten die interessen unserer länder
und diese treffen haben immer einen
pragmatischen charakter bitteschön
die ergebnisse dieses treffens haben sie
irgendwelche neuen illusionen geschöpft
ja ich hatte auch keine alten illusionen
warum sprechen sie über illusionen ich
habe keinerlei illusion und es dürfen
auch keine
ganz hinten bett oberste ja die dame
soll selbst entscheiden so fernsehsender
das lokale klima haben sie darüber
und sie haben ja vor kurzem ein großes
interview für ein essen wie sie geben
ist das dann gerecht zu einem interview
zustimmend während die us-amerikanischen
präsidenten den russischen medien keine
interviews gibt und wie schätzen sie das
gespräch ein
in bezug auf diese attacken oder was
nicht angesprochen wurde oder in wie
verzerrt wird
in den heutigen internationalen
beziehungen
ich bin das gewohnt mittlerweile seit
langem
wir leben damit seit vielen jahrzehnten
wer welche interviews gibt sie wenn er
etwas sagen will wenn er etwas an die
menschen heran traten will das war auch
der grund für mein interview
und was die zusammenarbeit mit den
massenmedien betrifft ja herr beiden hat
die frage gestellt über die frage wer
über die arbeit und die tätigkeit der
über das freie europa in russland ja
diese organisation wurde er von uns als
ausländische organisation eingestuft und
ich hatte das gefühl dass
die dass die beiden unternehmen und
nicht wussten wir haben ja nur zwei nur
zwei fernsehsender die im ausland tätig
sind das ist und noch ein unternehmen
wie folgt alle gesetze und alle
anforderungen der us amerikanischen
behörde sie registrieren sich aber es
werden ihnen immer probleme bereitet sei
erst das personal zu finden oder etwas
anderes verbindung aufzubauen aber wir
haben keinerlei probleme aber die
us-amerikanischen sender erfüllen nicht
die anforderungen der russischen
behörden und hier haben wir uns
ausgesprochen und wir haben dass wir
über das außenministerium diese
tätigkeit auch in die richtige bahn
ja ich wollte das eigentlich meinte ich
damit die dame und danach sie alle
gesehen wie sie die hand geschüttelt
abend ganz am anfang der gespräche
folgende frage haben sie ein neues
niveau den gesprächen vertraut
eine vertrauensbasis geschaffen es gibt
im leben kein glück es gibt hier nur den
anschein und genießen sie das in dieser
situation gibt es hier keine kein
familiäres vertrauen aber so die blicke
dieses vertrauens die haben wir gesehen
sie haben das mikro bitteschön
das corona wie aus dass es ist ja eine
wichtig ist dass das wichtigste thema wo
heutzutage wurde das thema gesprochen
wie könnte die zusammenarbeit aussehen
ich wieder um diese krankheit zu
bekämpfen
vielleicht eine gegenseitige anerkennung
der impfstoffe
ja wir haben das thema angesprochen aber
nur flüchtig wissen sie noch mit der
vorherigen administration haben wir die
sind wir der bitte nachgekommen und
haben unsere technischen ausrüstungen in
die usa geschickt
die usa sind ja natürlich ein sehr
starkes land
es gab die bitte wir haben wir sind der
bitte nach gegangen
ganz uneigennützig aber heute haben wir
das nicht detailliert gesprochen dass es
nicht schlechter wird
gibt es denn vielleicht einen boden von
dem wir ein tiefpunkt in dem er uns nach
oben abstoßen können alle handlungen zur
verschlechterung der beziehungen wurden
nicht von uns initiiert sondern von den
von der us amerikanischen seite die us
kongressabgeordneten ja die sind hier
sehr alexander ich weiß nicht ob sie
informiert sind aber die in russland hat
ein so 0 gewonnen gegen finnland
tabus der strategischen position weil
wir dieses treffen beiden und putin
darüber hinaus so betrachten wer hat
gewonnen wie die amerikaner haben ja im
vorfeld vor dem genfer treffen gesagt
wir werden druck ausüben
haben sie das auch so gespürt oder wie
konnten sie diesen look dagegen treten
das wird natürlich die russische
bevölkerung interessiert wie hat sich
unser präsident geschlagen ich denke das
reicht es gab keinerlei druck den ich
verspürte hätte das gespräch war offen
das war direkt ohne jegliche
diplomatische ausschweifungen vom thema
ich möchte nochmals wiederholen wieder
von unserer seite noch von der us
amerikanischen seite wurde keinerlei
druck ausgeübt
denn das wäre ja auch sinnlos denn man
trifft sich auch nicht dazu und
auszuüben
ja und was den endstand anbelangt beiden
hat gesagt das ist ja hier kein
sportlicher wettkampf und damit bin ich
vollkommen bei ihm das gespräch war
resultat ergebnis reich das war konkret
das war themenorientiert und verlief in
einer atmosphäre ergebnisorientiert war
und das wichtigste das waren diese
ausblicke und dieser dieses vertrauen
das ich vorhin bereits angesprochen habe
hat eine berechenbare und eine stabile
beziehung
russland trifft aber es gibt nicht mal
im westen sagt man da sei und nicht die
unberechenbarkeit ein charakter
suchmaschine der russischen föderation
ist haben sie denn vor diese
unberechenbarkeit von dieser
ungerechtigkeit abstand zu nehmen
können sie das gut verheimlichen was sie
sagen wollen
das erste sagen sie im westen sagt man
denkt man dass sie unberechenbar sind
und jetzt sagen sie
ob sie bereit sind berechenbarer zu
werden wer gut wenn man im westen so
denkt wenn das die russische
außenpolitik unberechenbar ist
die usa haben den vertrag 2002 in der
strategischen sicherheit gekündigt dann
das war ungerecht war dann 2009 10 die
kündigung des vertrages dann open skies
vertrag wurde auch gekündigt was ist
hier stabil es gab es gibt fast nichts
mehr
gut dass wir sind präsent beiden die
richtige die adäquate entscheidung
getroffen hat den start abkommen um fünf
jahre zu verlängern
wenn sie die situation mit der ukraine
unter krim sich ansehen
hier ist ja alles losgegangen
aber was ist daran so stabil in der
ukraine unterstützt worden ist alle
forderungen der opposition
man musste trotzdem umsturz unterstützen
und sie denken ja das wie unberechenbar
sind
ich bin damit nicht einfach
ich denke nicht so groß wir haben eine
adäquate antwort auf die bedrohungen die
wir sehen und damit die situation
tatsächlich stabiles müssen wir die
spielregeln die vorhandenen ansprechen
das ist die cyber sicherheit verlieren
das sind die fragen die mit regionaler
mit regionalen konflikten zu tun sondern
ich denke dass wir überall eine
übereinkunft treffen können und das ist
auch mein eindruck als ergebnis der
gespräche mit präsident biden die
täuschung den blauen nebel das verstehen
unsere ausländischen kollegen nicht
vielleicht sollten wir den ausländischen
medien das wort erteilen und dann
schließt ja bitte schön die sanktionen
sie sagen es gab das vertrauen das sie
hier
die us administration hat eine größere
solidarität in bezug auf die ukraine
die roten linien es macht keinen sinn
die seiten
dann macht und was die sanktionen
betrifft
ich weiß nicht wie die kräfte sind ja
gut wissen das aber wir kennen die
einzelheiten nicht wir wissen nicht
welche sich dort gerade es gibt es geht
aber befürworte und welche kräfte
weiß ich nicht aber wenn es lang unserem
treffen bestimmte schritte geben wird
2010 von 2016 also dann bedeutet dass
wir verschiedene scanner streichen haben
lassen brauchen sie eine übersetzung ja
kanada wollen sie nicht dazu schalten es
gibt keine übersetzung keine für
dolmetscher vielleicht ja machen sie mal
schalten sie mal auf anderen einen
anderen kanal immer noch nicht gar
nichts
im moment eingenommen haben und dass das
auch so auch weiter meine tochter
warum sagen sie es mit eigenen worten
warum ist dieses diese beziehung zu
schwierig und warum dürfen junge
menschen in russland nicht protestieren
dass ihre neunjährige tochter
interessiert ist in solchen fragen aber
die antwort ist sehr einfach und schauen
sie sich an wie
wie vollkommen die welt ist und wir
erwachsenen menschen von zwei atome
nicht an zwei größeren ländern sich
treffen um diese welt sicherer machen
diese welt trainiert ob das dieses haus
für alle das werden wir wohnen ein
glückliches zuhause ist dass sie werden
fragen erörtern
über die schrecklichen waffen eingedämmt
werden müssen sie werden über den schutz
der umwelt sprechen damit die flüsse und
damit die meere rein und sauber sind
damit es keine überschwemmungen dürren
gibt damit es keine lebensmittel
engpässe gibt
sie werden fragen der gesundheit fördern
damit die kinder in ihrem wachstum eine
sichere zukunft haben
ich möchte das heutige treffen auch
ausgehend aus diesen intentionen so auch
beleuchten werden
vielen dank für ihre aufmerksamkeit tja
so weit die pressekonferenz des
russischen präsidenten wladimir putin
nach dem ersten gipfel mit us-präsident
beiden diese pressekonferenz in genf hat
jetzt fast eine stunde gedauert
putin hat fragen und fragen und fragen
beantwortet und wir wollen während er
den pressekonferenz saal verlässt habe
mit einem auge im blick draußen im
garten der villa mit blick auf see steht
das pult und die amerikanische flagge wo
us-präsident beiden dann seine
pressekonferenz abgeben wird im moment
werden noch die mikrofone getestet es
scheint aber so zu sein dass der
amerikanische präsident wohl ganz
bewusst die pressekonferenz seines
gipfel
treffen partners putin abgewartet hat
eventuell wird er wahrscheinlich in den
nächsten minuten dann zum mikrofon
schreiben solange das mikrofon das pult
noch unbesetzt ist und wir auf beiden
warten wollen wir einfach schon mal ein
bisschen die rede und die antworten auf
die fragen der journalisten an von putin
analysieren und zwar mit tyson barker
der uns weiterhin aus bratislava
zugeschaltet ist von der deutschen
gesellschaft für auswärtige politik
putin hat gesagt das gespräch war offen
direkt ohne ausschweifungen weder von
uns noch von der us seite hat es druck
gegeben wie beurteilen sie was entnehmen
sie den worten putins wie das gespräch
abgelaufen ist
jetzt haben wir leider keinen ton ich
höre theissen barker nicht aha ist es
der klassiker in corona zeiten das mikro
ist zu ich höre noch immer nicht da
müssen die kollegen in der regie dann
auch mal gucken wir können so wir kennen
das in corona zeit noch kann ich sie
nicht hören herberger das jetzt geht es
ja was richtige mikrofon gefunden
wunderbar wie beurteilen sie das was
putin gesagt hat was entnehmen sie
putins worten an ergebnissen wie die
atmosphäre war beim gipfel was ist die
quintessenz also der hat gesagt es war
der wahl relativ entspannt würde ich
sagen der hat gesagt dass er betrachtet
beiden die beiden demonstrationen als
lösungsorientiert das sieht zwar als
zwei stunden lang gesprochen haben er
hat mehrmals gesagt dass beiden sehr
erfahren ist natürlich ist seine
mannschaft auch sehr erfahren auch was
russland angeht der hat das
charakterisiert als konstruktiv und hat
eine persönliche qualität zu beiden
gesagt nämlich er hat seine moralische
werte aufgehoben so ein kompliment
gegeben man muss schon sagen dass biden
ist sehr bekannt in washington für seine
emotionale intelligenz dass er ist gut
im badisch zu sein leute zu lesen zu
verstehen was ihre ziele sind was
wünsche sind ihre motivationen sind und
ich glaube auch durch diese
pressekonferenz haben wir das ein
bisschen bekommen so weit so sagen wir
mal persönlichen dynamik natürlich
würden jetzt aufhören von joe biden
selbst zu den themen die wichtig waren
wir haben gehört dass das start abkommen
verlängert wurde
wir haben gehört dass sie über ukraine
geredet haben
das beiden seiten das münchner abkommen
als als grundlage so festgelegt haben
oder dabei geblieben sind haben das
versichert allerdings denn der teufel
steckt im detail und gucken hat das auch
erwähnt dass die wahlen in der donbass
erst erstmals stattfinden sollen bevor
die truppenabzug stattfinden kann und
ich weiß dass das ist schon diese
reihenfolge wie die punkte in der
minsker abkommen durchgesetzt werden
sollen sind schon ein spannungs thema
also in den usa und im westlichen
ländern ist es gesehen dass das land
stabilisiert oder die dombach
stabilisiert werden muss dass es
wahlbeobachter geben muss da es die
sicherheitslage sicher werden muss die
truppen mussten abgezogen und erst
damals dass die wahlen die freien wahlen
stattfinden können die können nicht
stattfinden unter besatzung von
russischen truppen das ist die
auffassung von den usa
der hat es auch gesagt dass es keine
feindseligkeit gibt zwischen den beiden
ländern hat es angekündigt das ist neue
konzentrationen zu cyber geben wird das
ist eine stufe niedriger als
verhandlungen aber wieder mal diese
diese idee von kommunikation
kommunikationslinien zu öffnen
leitplanken zu etablieren das ist auch
im bereich cyber und atticus auch vor
bekommen
es gab ein paar beispiele wo er ein
klassischer putin taktik angewendet hat
hat gesagt dass die usa kritisiert mit
irak und afghanistan
als die journalisten nach keine und
syrien gefragt haben hat gefragt wie ist
das bedrohe nutzung mit guantanamo mit
kriminalität in den usa zum beispiel das
ist diese klassische moralische
äquivalenz diemand
mahler weise bei puten bekommt hatte
auch genutzt mit hinsicht auf die
unterdrückung von opposition in russland
hat er gesagt wir wollen kein wagnis
mörder wir wollen keine gewalt wie man
in den usa sieht und so weiter und so
fort aber im grossen ganzen bescheiden
ich würde sagen schon recht relaxt und
mit ich glaube die haben das ziel
erreicht nämlich strategische stabilität
damit anzufangen das ein bisschen zu
bauen zwischen den beiden seiten so
sagen wenn ich das so ein bisschen
zusammenfassen was sie meinen wenn man
einmal anfängt mit so ein paar steinchen
mit ein paar ziegelsteine dann hat man
nicht gar nicht die ganze mauer
eingerissen aber es ist zumindest malen
beginnt mit den einfachen sachen anfängt
nicht dass die botschafter wieder
zurückkehren können
da kann man ja mal so ein häkchen dran
machen und sagen es sieht mal wir haben
uns geeinigt damit hat er die
pressekonferenz angefangen damit fängt
das ganze an
aber das ist natürlich auch das
einfachste dass die botschafter wieder
zurückkehren und es ist jetzt noch kein
neues abrüstungsabkommen da haben sie
völlig recht
sie haben gerade gesagt was putin so ein
bisschen zwischen den zahlen ja auch
gesagt hat über beiden dass er durchaus
erwähnt hat dass er moralische werte hat
dass man vielleicht beiden auch so ein
bisschen schätzte er hat ja auch erzählt
dass beiden ein bisschen persönlich
geworden ist was er mit seiner mutter
bespricht und dies sind das in jenes es
ist ja so es sind zwei anführer zweier
gigantischer atommächten was beide
gemeinsam haben ist ja dass sie eine
riesengroße eine gigantische machtfülle
sozusagen haben aber beiden ist er seit
150 tagen im amt putin schon seit 21
jahren ist es trotzdem so trotz dieser
gigantischen unterschiede ich glaube
auch in moskau nicht nur strom sondern
auch in moskau bezeichnet man beiden oft
als sleepy jo weil er sich in seinem
habitus ja manchmal so ein bisschen wie
ein großvater oder so bewegt aber ist es
so dass hier doch beiden nicht zu
unterschätzen ist und sie doch auf
augenhöhe heute gesprochen haben also
ich glaube beiden ist auf keinen fall zu
unterschätzen
er hat auch gesagt dass im gegensatz zu
seinem vorgänger
damals schon war er sehr detailliert
man muss sagen dass biden ist nicht neu
in diesem thema der ist zum ersten mal
in den 70ern in der sowjetunion gereist
und um ehrlich zu sein in diese diese
hochebene der der politik und der
internationale beziehungen ist beiden
viel erfahrener muss man sagen also
sogar als das blatt und weil der war
vorsitzender des senats ausschuss für
auswärtige politik jahrelang im senat
fast 40 jahre lang acht jahre lang vize
präsident und präsident also der hat
schon ein ziemlich beeindruckt mit
lebenslauf und hat viele abkommen eine
erfahrung hat viele dynamiken zwischen
russland und den usa erfahren der mauer
sowjetunion zerfall die zeit der letzten
zeit die bush zeit auch eben im kongress
die reset das was es nicht geben wird
das war etwas was er versucht hatte
wirklich konstruktiv ein dialog
aufzubauen mit mitglieder und der hat
ein sehr langes gedächtnis
also insofern sagen sie das war schon
sehr pointiert von putin wieder gesagt
hat ich habe gesehen dass er sehr er
also beiden sehr erfahren ist nicht mit
allen staatschefs können wir so lange
sprechen
ich glaube dass da fast ja das ja
eigentlich zusammen putin was sie meinen
dass beiden sehr informiert ist über
sehr viel sprechen kann weil er eben
diese erfahrung hat und weil er dieses
wissen hat und nicht nur mit so ein paar
sprüchen daherkommt und wenn er
vielleicht von seiner mutter oder
großmutter erzählt hat er glaube ich das
sagen sie dieses gespür dafür wann ich
wie eine persönliche anekdote einsätze
und was will ich in dem gespräch
erreichen
wir schauen mit einem auge weiterhin
sozusagen in den garten der villa la
crash mit dem genfersee im hintergrund
stars and stripes riesengroß die
amerikanische fahne sehen wir auch das
pult ist noch leer die journalisten
sitzen und warten auf den amerikanischen
präsidenten
der sollen wir den eindruck glaube ich
sehr bewusst auch so bewusst wir in
dieses treffen reingegangen ist sehr
bewusst auch die den zeitpunkt wählt
wann er seine pressekonferenz geben wird
er hat ja nun nicht parallel begonnen
hat präsident putin seine
pressekonferenz beenden lassen
wir wissen es nicht vielleicht macht er
sich jetzt noch ein paar notizen um eine
replik abzugeben um darauf zu reagieren
wir werden es auf jeden fall gleich
sehen nutzen aber die zeit nochmal
weiterhin mit theissen weiter zu
sprechen was erwarten sie denn jetzt
eigentlich von beiden was er wohl sagen
wird also ich glaube der wird versuchen
ein bisschen zuzuspitzen was die was er
für rote linien und konsequenzen für
bestimmte aktionen und maßnahmen
artikuliert hat in dem treffen im
bereich cyber im bereich des information
hier berät krieg wir haben auch gehört
von von wladimir putin dass so viele
anfragen in die usa angekommen sind und
wurden nie geantwortet und dass putin
hat gesagt dass die usa ist der
herkunftsland nummer eins für
cyberattacken in der welt ich habe es
noch geschaut
während das das ist nicht wahr die
nummer eins ist china mit 41 prozent
insgesamt
die usa ist allerdings nummer zwei
gefolgt von russland und die türkei
er hat gesagt kann er da ist nummer zwei
glaube ich aber ich glaube er wird schon
zeigen weil das ist natürlich eine
botschaft an die amerikanische
bevölkerung dass es schon konstruktiv
aber gehaltenen gesprächen waren dass
das ist das bedeutet kein reset es
bedeutet keine erneuerung dieser
beziehungen es war eine pragmatisches
gespräch weil er sein ziel ist diese
stabilität zu schaffen dass russland zu
keine ablenkung in seinem politischen
agenda wird es diese massen die truppen
massen an der grenze zu überqueren
er hat dazu geführt dass die beiden
investitionen ursprünglich dieses
angebot gemacht hat weil sie hatten
angst dass wieder mal russland auch in
der cyber attacken zur destabilisierung
in der welt führen könnte und das könnte
ihm von seinen eigentlichen politischen
programm ein bisschen ablenken nämlich
dieser vier punkte die drei cs und das
andere china klima co wird und dann die
wirtschaft wiederaufbau in den usa nach
der kuppe zeit also der will sich
wirklich darauf konzentrieren eine
bescheidene gruppe von von von
leitplanken etablieren und dann wieder
mal in die usa
und diese prioritäten fokussieren wir
sehen parallel dass das rednerpult noch
leer ist wir warten also weiterhin auf
den us-präsidenten der wurde ja in
washington sogar ein bisschen dafür
kritisiert dass er sozusagen diese
einladung ausgesprochen hat dass er das
war seine idee ein gipfeltreffen mit
putin auf neutralem grund in der schweiz
hat er also vorgeschlagen und manch ein
kritiker beiden das hat sie in
washington gesagt das sei ja eine art
belohnung für putin diese einladung
putin würde sozusagen diese einladung
als gewinn verbuchen beiden hat immer
wieder wiederholt er hat es auch heute
wir haben es anfangs gesehen als er da
in der bibliothek saß hat er es ja auch
noch mal gesagt ich denke es ist besser
sich von angesicht zu angesicht zu
treffen
damit hat ja eigentlich heute selbst
heute noch einmal verteidigt warum er
diese einladung ausgesprochen hat putin
hat aber nun in seiner pressekonferenz
das durchaus auch wiederholt dass er die
einladung beiden gewesen der er gerne
gefolgt sei ist es doch so eine art
belohnung ist das ein punkt den putin
für sich verbucht ich bin eingeladen
worden
auf jeden fall also das vorher immer so
gesehen das war immer also diese
einladungen waren immer sehr streng
choreografiert in der vergangenheit es
kam nur nach viel arbeit intensiver
arbeit zwischen 2
es ist eine belohnung mit dem
amerikanischen präsident zu treffen so
eine weltmacht eine großmacht wie die
usa und die man muss zu sagen dass die
die website hat das alles ein bisschen
aus dem ruder gebracht und auch dass
diese beziehung und die abrechenbar kite
dieser beziehung vernachlässigt wurde
und um das wieder einmal in gang zu
bringen war das der meinung des weißen
hauses fast unvermeidbar also man muss
eine normalität wieder schaffen
und man hat es gesehen durch die
eskalation durch diese truppen ein zug
an der grenze zur ukraine
durch diese cyber attacken dass man muss
das wirklich auch lieder ebene schon 1 1
basis regeln das hat putin ja am ende
auch sehr nett auf die kanadische
journalistin gesagt dass es doch schön
ist wenn zwei staatschefs von zwei
riesengroßen atommächten sich treffen
gemeinsam reden um die welt sicherer zu
machen die schöne welt sicherer zu
machen die umwelt zu verbessern dass die
flüsse sauberer sein et cetera also die
bedeutung die putin sozusagen diesem
treffen auch noch einmal gibt welche
rolle spielten wohl in russland dieser
gipfel wird putin damit punkten und
sagen seht her ich bin doch euer
staatsmann und seht her wie ich eben
sozusagen russland zu größe führe
denn ich glaube die sanktionen treffen
ja die bevölkerung darunter leidet man
auch wenn putin hingeht und sagt was
haben wir denn ein großartiges verloren
die usa verlieren durch die sanktionen
viel mehr als wir aber sozusagen diese
einladungen sie haben ja auch gerade
gesagt das hebt doch wieder putins rolle
auch in der welt wird er dann in dieser
form punkten spielt deshalb dieser
gipfel eine große rolle auch in russland
auf jeden fall also diese diese dieses
staates als großmarkt zu behalten zu
erhalten ist ein großer teil der
legitimität 54 punkten der versuch zu
zeigen dass russland ist nicht im abgang
sondern es ist immer noch eine großmacht
und hat eine historisch bedeutende rolle
immer noch und diese dieses treffen ist
ein zeichen dafür
hinsichtlich und noch was dazu zu sagen
2014 hat obama gesagt in der höhepunkt
der ukraine krise dass russland eine
regionalmacht war das wurde betrachtet
als eine große beleidigung in russland
dass eine abstufung von seiner großmarkt
status und heute vor diesem treffen hat
joe biden gesagt offensichtlich sehr
bewusst das ist ein treffen zwischen
zwei großmächte sind das ist die wieder
einmal diese aufregung aufhebung auf
dieser stadt ist groß macht und das wird
sicherlich sehr intensive in russland
auch berichtet dass russland als
großmacht wahrgenommen wird von den usa
und wird politisch wladimir putin sehr
sehr helfen
ich muss auch sagen obwohl die die
kuppel zahlen steigen in russland ist
die stabilität und die konsolidierung im
kreml unguten schon vorangebracht durch
die höheren ölpreisen
also es ist wirklich eine gewissermaßen
gute zeit für puten auch ökonomisch auch
mit der basis der wirtschaft durch öl
und gas und dass diese symbol großmacht
stadt ist wie der erreicht zu haben in
den usa wird ihm sicherlich auch dabei
helfen
wir haben putin erlebe ja bei der
pressekonferenz tolstoi zitiert hat ging
so ein bisschen die frage der
journalisten in die richtung wie gut man
sich denn jetzt versteht ich hab's ja
auch eingangs gesagt dass man nach genf
guckt und ja auch ein bisschen neugierig
ist ob die beiden putin und daneben
einen draht finden der die beziehung ja
auch verbessern kann
und als die frage eben war ja gibt es
jetzt ein vertrauensbeweis ist ein
vertrauen geschaffen worden in dem
gespräch hat putin geantwortet und
tolstoi zitiert es gibt im leben kein
glück es gibt nur den anschein aber
genießen sie es was hat er damit zum
ausdruck gebracht dass beide erfahrene
player sind auf dieser großen
internationalen politischen bühne
ja genau ich glaube auch wenn es
politische oder sagen wir mal
persönliche dynamischen gibt
letztendlich hat er gesagt ist es geht
um die pragmatismus
zwei staaten die ihre eigenen interessen
vertreten und die interaktion zwischen
diesen staatsmännern und ihre interessen
ihres landes ist das was wirklich zählt
und die beiden sind sehr geschickt um
das zu vertreten und also letztendlich
man kann eine gute persönliche beziehung
haben oder eben nicht und das ist schon
wichtig für die beziehung zwischen zwei
ländern aber letztendlich geht es um
harte realpolitik und das ist sicherlich
das kennwort das stichwort dieses
treffens heute das ist glaube ich nicht
falsch wenn wir das wiederholen was er
eben schon gesagt haben dass nun oder
die mir putin seit 21 jahren an der
macht ist regiert in russland in
verschiedensten formen und natürlich ein
tougher harter realpolitiker ist und man
könnte man kann wir können das nicht
nachprüfen weil wir natürlich nicht in
den drähten dabei sind zwischen ihm dem
übersetzer dem ohr knopf wladimir putin
aber als ein westlicher journalist eine
kritische frage gestellt hat da kamen
daneben oder das ist nicht übersetzt
worden wir können weil präsident beide
noch nicht da ist einmal ganz kurz noch
mal da rein hören und über diese szene
einfach noch mal gemeinsam diskutieren
ok ich höre dass das haben wir nicht
aber wenn es ja beide gesehen
heissenberger das war der journalist er
dann gesagt noch einmal das mikrofon
sich gegriffen hat und gesagt hat
sie haben aber meine zweite frage die
ich gestellt habe nicht beantwortet wie
sieht es denn aus mit menschenrechten
ist das alles angesprochen worden und
daraufhin hatte putin gesagt ja das ist
wohl nicht übersetzt worden und hat das
ganze dann ein bisschen beiseite
geschoben ist das auch so ein spiel das
man mal sagte da hat der dolmetscher
glaube ich gesagt wer war sicherlich
also diese journalistin hat gefragt ob
er angst hat vor opposition legitime
opposition und er hat gesagt erstmals
hat er gesagt ja die micro hat nicht
funktioniert dann hat er gesagt dass
eine warme und seine organisation die
jetzt als terroristisch eingestuft ist
das ist alles nach den dem gesetz in
russland allerdings ist das gesetz und
wie es funktioniert als waffe genutzt in
russland es ist kein instrument es ist
nicht für rechtsstaatlichkeit sondern
selektiver rechtsstaatlichkeit die gegen
die feinde von von dem kreml und von
denen die marktstruktur angewendet wird
und dann hat er sofort und das ist auch
ein sehr klassische putin taktik
versucht das in den usa um zu wickeln
und zu sagen sie sind alle heuchler weil
genau das gleiche passiert in den usa
schaue mir das anschaue mal das an das
wollen wir nicht das wollen wir nicht
also diese moralische äquivalenz in
dieser hinsicht hat er gesagt wenn man
die protesten und massen aufstände in
den usa anschaut und wie es gewalttätig
ist mit blattwerk auch mit den augen auf
sturm auf dem kongress das ist etwas was
wir vermeiden wollen und das ist
sicherlich die wahrnehmung die in
russland
promoviert ist dass das was man sieht
dort der hat es auch eingebracht dass
die die navalny bewegung versucht
molotow cocktails auf polizisten und
minderjährigen zu werfen und die an zu
anzugreifen und das ist natürlich wie
wir sehen in einem robusten
zivilgesellschaft mit einem monat
hingegen medien
das ist nicht der fall aber die der raum
für unabhängige medien ist so begrenzt
in russland auch jetzt druck medien dass
das ist sicherlich die wahrnehmung die
dort vermehrt wird sprich das anders ist
so ein bisschen putin eben die
retourkutsche die er gerne spielt es war
ja so ein punkt das beiden jahr vorher
mal gesagt hatte er das wort killer in
den mund genommen hat
als er über putin gesprochen hat dann
noch mal darauf angesprochen hat er
geschmunzelt das ist glaube ich auch
eine sache die putin so ein bisschen
gereizt hat da eine kur die
retourkutsche sozusagen abzufeuern zu
liefern das hat er gemacht indem er eben
gesagt hat wer ist denn der mörder und
hat daneben
viele sachen aufgezählt das auf den
straßen in den usa eben menschen sterben
und diese sage ich mal retourkutsche die
haben wir auch noch mal raus geschnitten
aus der pk auf den straßen der usa wird
jeden tag jemand getötet
man sagt irgendwas und dann wird schon
gleich geschossen entweder auf die brust
oder in den rücken
eine frau hat ist aus dem auto gestiegen
ist weggelaufen sie wurde erschossen
ja das sind verbrechen aber afghanistan
mit einem schlag auf einen schlag werden
120 personen umgebracht ganze hochzeiten
nehmen wir an dass das ein fehler ist
aber ermordung drohnen oder aus
helikoptern von zivilen personen im irak
was ist das wer ist dafür verantwortlich
wer ist der mörder ja also eine gewisse
retourkutsche sie können ja noch mal
erklären worauf er daran spielt ja also
es kommt immer wieder vor wir haben es
auch gesehen bei als ein journalist nach
dem medienfreiheit gesprochen hat und
die rechte von radio free europe radio
liberty die nach und nach aus dem land
rausgeworfen ist und eigentlich vier der
besten journalisten russischsprachigen
journalisten im land einstellt und er
hat gesagt ja also wir haben unsere
gesetze für ausländische organisationen
die haben sie nicht verfolgt die haben
sie nicht gefolgt genau so muss das
machen was schätze day in den usa und
wieder mal diese diese klassische
moralische clevelands ins spiel gebracht
das hat er auch gemacht mit mit diese
mit dieser vergleich zwischen diese
betrachtung von ihm als killer und
oppositions unterdrücker und die
einsetzung von drohnen und whitehall und
kriminalität in den usa aber das wird er
auch machen möchte weil der hat
natürlich sein publikum was in russland
ist ein
die bestimmtes bild der usa zu
bestätigen und das ist ein bild von
einem heuchlerischen land der russland
angreift wegen oppositions unterdrückung
wegen mord wegen aktionen abenteuer
krieg in syrien in libyen in ukraine
aber was er sagen möchte ist es ist
nichts anderes als das was die usa macht
und ich glaube dass es und man liest
viel darüber
das ist was er wirklich glaubt er glaubt
es gibt keinen unterschied zwischen die
aktionen von russland in diesen proxy
kriegen in ukraine in in syrien und die
aktionen der usa in afghanistan und irak
und das ist ein bild was er versucht
wirklich zu prägen in russland und das
hatte wieder bestätigt in diesem in
dieser pressekonferenz
wir warten ja weiter auf die
pressekonferenz mit dem amerikanischen
präsidenten joe biden während wir warten
einfach mal einige meinungen und
kommentare unserer user die genauso
gebannt warten und sich natürlich auch
gedanken machen und wissen wie wichtig
dieses treffen ist stevia schreibt es
wäre wirklich wichtig für europa einen
erneuten kalten krieg zu verhindern
in die gleiche richtung geht manukau
witz über youtube schreibt sie ich
persönlich hoffe für uns alle das uns in
den kommenden jahrzehnten kriege egal ob
groß oder klein erspart bleiben auch ein
neuer kalter krieg wäre sicher für
niemanden wünschenswert also gucken
viele auch unsere userinnen und user
gebannt auf diesen gipfel
ob eben diese eiszeit zwischen
washington und moskau
ob der wenigstens ein bisschen ein
eiszapfen schmilzt und es fortschritte
gibt eine gewisse annäherung was zu
einer stabileren situation führen kann
frage noch mal an unseren experten an
teyssen barker putin ist ja nun heute
direkt von moskau aus nach genf gekommen
direkt angereist beiden dagegen hatte
eine ganze europa tour hinter sich war
in cornwall beim g7-gipfel alles
die westlichen starke industriestaaten
war beim nato-gipfel und beim gipfel mit
der eu hat beiden sich da sozusagen
unterstützung geholt um mit rückenwind
nach genf zu fahren und putin zu treffen
ja das ist ein ausgezeichnet denn die
die besondere wert der usa ist dass es
dass es umkreist ist von allianzen das
ist nicht immer wertgeschätzt in den usa
vor allem in den letzten - traktion
offensichtlich das sehr unilateral tätig
war und die bush-administration aber
etwas was sehr wichtig ist für die
demokraten war diese allianzen
strukturen zu festzulegen zu verstärken
und das hat er sicherlich gemacht also
erstmals in der g7 offensichtlich bei
der nato haben sie über die bedrohung
von russland gesprochen und den er hat s
angeboten dass die stärkung von artikel
5 bleibt dass die usa ist immer noch
dazu verpflichtet und das war diese
diese wackel stimmung der traumzeit ist
jetzt vorbei und dann vor allem in der
eu
denn viele der instrumente die die die
usa und europa zur verfügung haben sind
geo ökonomischen instrumenten nicht
klassischen kriegerischen instrumenten
wie militär diesem sanktionen die sind
wie russland integriert ist in der
weltwirtschaft es ist das internet ist
sind themen sachen wo die eu eine
wichtige rolle spielen wird und bei der
us eu gipfel haben die beiden seiten
einen russland dialog miteinander auch
etabliert um das zu verbessern ihrer
koordinierung und heute hat auch die
extorre-aktien service also das
außenministerium der europäischen
kommission angekündigt dass es wird eine
neue russland strategie geben und sie
haben auch versucht die erwartungen
realistisch zu halten haben gesagt die
beziehung zwischen die eu und russland
sind nicht gut und würden wahrscheinlich
im kommenden monaten sich verschlechtern
und also sie sind auch sehr realistisch
in brüssel wie die beziehung sich
entwickeln und diese elemente und es ist
ähnlich mit china mit dem anderen großen
autoritären macht das was sie nicht
haben ist diese vernetzung diese allianz
strukturen die die usa hat und das ist
ein mehrwert die kein anderer großmacht
dieser maß wirklich hat und das hat er
natürlich hierher nach camp gebracht ja
es sind ja immer spekulationen ja auch
zeichen signale die man schickt
sozusagen das machen sie ja gerade
deutlich
wir haben ja schon darüber gesprochen
dass hat diesen großen truppenaufmarsch
gegeben russische truppen an der grenze
zur östlichen ukraine da haben ja viele
beobachter politischen korrespondenten
etc die ja auch schon gemutmaßt und so
weiter ist das vielleicht eine art und
weise dass putin den neuen präsidenten
einfach mal testen will die muskeln so
ein bisschen spielen lassen will um mal
zu gucken ob er nervös wird und wie er
reagiert und würden sie dann sagen ist
so ein bisschen dieser europa diese
europareise von beiden die antwort
gewesen wenn er doch sehr bei dem nato
gipfel immer wieder auf artikel 5
geklopft hat und die diese
verpflichtungen den beistand deutlich
unterstrichen hat um sozusagen damit das
signal zu geben
nein ich habe schon gesehen was du da
machst aber wenn du irgendwie
weitergehen sollte ist die rote linie
überschreiten solltest wir stehen fest
an der seite auch zu den baltischen
staaten und zu anderen staaten ja ich
glaube das war eines der ziele
sicherlich ist es sehr wichtig für joe
biden auch einen schulterschluss zu
zeigen mit dem baltikum weil die sind
wirklich die länder mit einer großen
russischen minderheit
die sind die länder die wirklich
indirekt an der grenze sind die
landschaft ist der flach die sind schwer
zu verteidigen und sie sind wirklich auf
die artikel 5 sehr angewiesen das ist
ihr punkt das ist eines der gründe warum
diese länder
die wollen immer im kern der allianz
seien sowohl in der nato als auch in der
eu das ist der grund warum es ihnen so
wichtig war auch in der finanzkrise zu
euro zukommen
sie haben es als geopolitische
sehen sie wir haben gesagt wir wollen
nicht an der peripherie seien am rande
europa sein sondern wir wollen mitten
drin in europa sein und wir wollen
dritten mittendrin in der
transatlantischen allianz sein und das
ist etwas also joe biden hat langer zeit
mit dem baltikum mit polen zusammen
gearbeitet
die haben mehrere botschaften twitter
fotos treffen verbreitet von der nato
gipfel also diese sind diese
sicherstellen war eine sehr wichtige
elemente und es ist auch eine gewisse
neben botschaft an russland zu sagen wir
würden bei ihnen zusammen stehen und sie
haben recht sie haben es gesagt also die
die truppenbewegungen an der grenze zur
ukraine hat mehreren gründen aber eines
davon war die neue verhaltensmuster der
beiden demonstrationen zu testen und zu
sehen wie sie darauf reagieren würden
und die tatsache ist es nicht zu einer
eskalation gekommen ist zeit also dass
es reine spekulation natürlich haben wir
nicht in einen blick in die die
kommunikationen aber es zeigt zumindest
dass das die beiden ländern also die
alle länder die menz gruppe ukraine usa
und russland haben einen weg gefunden um
das ein bisschen zumindest zu
deeskalieren und das ist eine gute sache
vielen dank schon mal bis hierhin für
die einschätzungen teilen barker sie
haben wahrscheinlich auch gesehen dass
einige journalisten in genf sich doch
dann mal trotz der hitze das sakko
angezogen haben ob das jetzt ein zeichen
ist das auch noch mal das
präsidentensiegel das wappen am
rednerpult gerichtet wird
ob das hinweise sind das tatsächlich ist
der us-präsident kommt wissen wir nicht
ganz genau aber wir hoffen wir hoffen
dass einfach mal
es heißt jetzt fließt justiz das könnte
ein deutliches zeichen sein dass der
us-präsident jetzt kommt sie und ich
haben es festgestellt drei minuten sind
es nicht gewesen die jetzt beiden
sozusagen nach putin spricht aber ich
hab es auch schon gesagt wer weiß
vielleicht hat er eben ganz absichtlich
die pressekonferenz von putin abgewartet
um darauf zu reagieren sich vielleicht
noch notizen zu machen und jetzt seine
sichtweise zu erklären wie er dieses
gipfeltreffen gesehen hat und was die
ergebnisse in seinen augen sind wir
haben es bereits besprochen einiges
nicht alles haben wir von putin bereits
gehört dass die gespräche offen waren
ergebnisorientiert themenorientiert eine
atmosphäre die jetzt von putin nicht als
herzlich freundschaftlich
kameradschaftlich bezeichnet worden ist
sondern ergebnisorientiert aber man muss
ganz ehrlich sein das glaube ich niemand
heißenberg hat es auch schon deutlich
gemacht glaube ich niemand ernsthaft
erwartet hat das jetzt hier zwei männer
sich zum ersten mal treffen nach der
jahrelangen eiszeit zwischen washington
und moskau und es sofort ein
freundschaftliches verhältnis gibt
vielleicht ist dieses zitat von tolstoi
was putin gebracht hat dass es im leben
kein glück es gibt nur den anschein also
nach dem motto wenn es immer so aussieht
als ob neue männerfreundschaften oder
überhaupt freundschaften zwischen
regierungschefs staatschefs gebildet
werden das man hinterfragen muss ob das
wirklich so ist oder ob das nicht
interessengeleitet ist das war
vielleicht so ein bisschen die antwort
von putin darauf dass auch er jetzt oder
niemand erwarten können sollte dass es
jetzt eine riesengroße freundschaft
zwischen ihm und beiden auf die frage ob
beiden ihn denn nun ins weiße haus
eingeladen hat hat's putting antwortet
nein das hat er nicht hat aber insofern
fairerweise das entschuldigt ich habe ja
beiden auch noch nicht eingeladen ein
bisschen angedeutet nach dem motto man
kann sich ja noch ein paar mal treffen
oder zumindest sprechen um dann weitere
schritte in diese richtung zu machen
zumindest klang ist ja schon mal positiv
an dass putin gesagt hat dass er die
moralischen werte
doch bei beiden hoch lobt dass er beiden
als sehr erfahren bezeichnet hat putin
hat auch deutlich gesagt dass man nicht
mit allen staatschefs nicht mit allen
regierungs oder staatschefs so lange
sprechen kann
tyson barker hat es eben
eingeordnet ist das zeigt auch dass
putin vielleicht durchaus schätzt dass
beiden kein unerfahrener präsident ist
er ist 250 tage im amt aber er hat viele
viele stationen schon gehabt er kennt
russland er kennt sich bestens aus auf
der diplomatischen auf der politischen
internationalen bühne
das heißt er weiß sehr gut wie die dinge
gespielt werden genauso wie putin mit
seinen 21 jahren an der macht das auch
weiß das heißt ein bisschen habe ich
schon aus der pressekonferenz von putin
entnehmen können dass die beiden männer
doch wohl auf augenhöhe gesprochen haben
und zumindest das auch aneinander
schätzen dass sie erfahren sind was
diese gipfeltreffen was solche wichtigen
treffen angeht ja wir hören dass der
präsident kommt da kommt us präsident
joe biden und wir hören nun rein in
seiner pressekonferenz was er zu sagen
hat
ich denke es war kein problem sie
hierher zu kommen und darf sie alle
begrüßen
jetzt bin ich ja das letzte meeting
dieser langen reise in dieser woche ist
jetzt zu ende gegangen
dieses gipfeltreffen es gab ja sehr viel
hype drumherum aber die bedeutung für
mich eigentlich ganz klar es gibt keinen
ersatz für einen dialog zwischen
führungspersönlichkeiten direkten dialog
präsident putin und ich haben beide die
verantwortung die beziehungen zwischen
zwei stolzen großen ländern zu regeln
eine beziehung bedeckt die stabil und
berechenbar sein muss ich wir sollten in
der lage sein zu kooperieren wo es in
unserem beidseitigen interesse ist wir
haben auch differenz
wo ich möchte das herr putin versteht
warum ich sage was ich sage was ich tue
und wie ich auch auf bestimmte
handlungen reagiere die gegen
amerikanische interessen verstoßen
ich habe präsident putin gesagt meine
agenda heißt nicht dass ich gegen
russland bin sondern für das
amerikanische volk
bezüglich corona haben wir unser land
wieder aufgebaut wir stehen zu unseren
alliierten und freunden und schützen das
amerikanische volk das ist meine
verantwortung als präsident
ich habe eben auch gesagt dass kein
präsident der vereinigten staaten
dem amerikanischen volk entgegen treten
kann wenn er nicht die demokratischen
werte vertritt 1 steht für die
universellen und fundamenten freiheiten
die alle menschen in unserer sicht haben
das gehört zur dna unseres landes die
menschenrechte werden immer ein thema
sein für uns es geht nicht darum etwas
gegen russland zu sagen weil sie die
menschenrechte verletzen
als präsident der vereinigten staaten
von amerika muss man gegen verstöße
gegen die menschenrechte
etwas sagen auch andere länder
einschließlich russland die das haben
sie von mir auch schon vorher gehört und
das sage ich wieder hier anschauen und
wo wir sagen wir verzichten nicht auf
unsere rechte wir haben rechte als
menschen weil wir geboren sind und das
sind rechte die wir eine regierung
übertragen
das habe ich der präsidenten gesagt und
deshalb haben wir auch besorgnis
bezüglich eines falles wie den von
alexei navalny ich habe präsident putin
gesagt ich werde weiterhin solche
fundamentalen menschenrechtsthemen auf
den tisch bringen
denn das sind wir so sind wir das ist
wirklich selbstverständlich dass alle
menschen alle männer frauen diese rechte
haben und deshalb treten wir dafür ein
und
das gilt für mehr und mehr menschen ich
habe auch zwei in russland inhaftierte
amerikanische bürger den fall von radio
free europe radio liberty habe ich
erwähnt die bedeutung einer freien
presse und der redefreiheit und ich habe
auch gesagt wir werden versuchen unsere
demokratische souveränität zu
beeinträchtigen nicht durchgehen lassen
wir werden reagieren und unter dem
strich habe ich präsident putin gesagt
wir brauchen grundregeln leitplanken an
die wir uns alle halten können es gibt
auch bestimmte gebiete wo wir ein
gemeinsames interesse haben an einer
kooperation für alle menschen die
russischen und die amerikanischen
menschen und natürlich auch die menschen
in der welt mit ihren in
sicherheitsinteressen und ein thema ist
eben die strategische stabilität sie
haben mich mehrfach gefragt was werden
sie mit putin diskutieren
ich kann ihnen jetzt sagen was ich
eigentlich schon lange vor hatte das
thema strategische stabilität
aufzubringen und einen mechanismus an zu
sprechen wie wir damit umgehen können
wir haben detailliert die nächsten
schritte unserer länder geben bezug auf
die rüstungskontrolle diskutiert
schritte die notwendig sind um einen
unbeabsichtigten konflikt zu vermeiden
und wir haben uns heute geeinigt
bilateralen strategischen dialogs zu
führen
das ist diplomatisch ausgedrückt dafür
das militär experten und diplomaten sich
zusammensetzen und an einem mechanismus
arbeiten mit dem man neue und
gefährliche waffen die jetzt auf die
szene kommen eingrenzen können
da müssen wir reagieren das sind ja eben
gefahren für unbeabsichtigte konflikte
die aufkommen ein anderes thema mit dem
wir sehr viel zeit verbracht haben ist
die cyber sicherheit
ich habe über die vorschläge gesprochen
dass bestimmte kritische angebote nicht
mehr attackiert sein sollen ich habe ihm
eine liste gegeben
ich habe die liste jetzt hier aber ich
glaube standen 16
spezifische punkte drauf
16 kritische infrastruktur probleme vom
energiesektor bis zur wasserversorgung
denn das prinzip dieses das muss war
auch kann sich praktisch umsetzbar sein
und länder müssen auch gegen kriminelle
vorgehen
die zb grenzen wer attacken auf deren
gebiet durchführen und erpressungen
durchführung beide unserer länder
da waren wir uns einig arbeiten an einem
spezifischen verständnis dessen was
nicht geht und was spezifische fälle
sind die in den einzelnen ländern ihren
ursprung haben über viele andere dinge
haben wir auch gesprochen über die
notwendigkeit eine humanitäre lösung in
syrien zu finden dass man nahrungsmittel
und grundversorgung nach syrien bringen
muss wie man das aufbauen kann und wie
das auch im interesse russlands ebenso
wie der vereinigten staaten ist dass der
iran nicht nuklear waffen in die hand
bekommt daran arbeiten wir zusammen denn
es ist genauso russlands interesse wie
das unsere und auch darüber wie wir
sicherstellen können dass die arktis ein
kooperations gebiet bleibt und nicht ein
ort an dem es konflikte gibt ich habe
präsident pressekonferenz ja auch gehört
er sprach auch über die notwendigkeit
dass wir ein modus operandi brauchen mit
dem wir sicher stehen köln dass die
arktis eine freie zone bleibt und wie
wir jeweils dazu beitragen können dass
wir auch terrorismus in afghanistan
verhindern können und ein wiederaufleben
des terrorismus das ist genauso im
interesse russlands wie in unserem
interesse dass das nicht passiert und
ich habe auch gesagt dass die usa die
souveränität und die territoriale
integrität der ukraine weiter verfolgen
wir werden uns da diplomatisch auf das
münster abkommen stützen
und ich habe auch die besorgnisse
bezüglich belarus geäußert er war nicht
anderer meinung
hat nur eine andere perspektive was zu
tun ist da gibt es viele viele fragen
lassen sie mich also mit dieser
bemerkung schließen
es war wichtig ihn persönlich zu treffen
als es da kann es keine
missverständnisse dessen geben was ich
kommunizieren wollte ich habe das getan
was ich wollte nämlich themen genannt wo
wir praktisch zusammenarbeiten können um
unsere gemeinsamen interessen zu
verfolgen und etwas gutes für die welt
zu tun und zum zweiten dass wir direkt
kommunizieren und das haben wir sagt
dass die usa ihre eigenen interessen und
die der alliierten vertreten und zum
dritten
dass wir unsere prioritäten und die
werte unserer länder klar sagen und sie
haben von mir das ja eindeutig auch
gehört und ich muss sagen der ton dieser
meetings insgesamt war es ja vier
stunden da war gut der wahl position ist
es gab da überhaupt keinen scharfen töne
wir hatten diskrepanzen und haben das
gesagt er hat es gesagt ich habe es
gesagt aber das war keine aufgeheizte
atmosphäre denn es ging ja eigentlich
auch um viel zu viele dinge in dieser
letzten woche denke ich haben die usa
der welt gezeigt dass wir zurück sind
dass wir zu unseren alliierten stehen
dass wir unsere demokratien unserer
partner wirklich dazu führen dass wir
die größten herausforderungen annehmen
wir haben eine klare grundlage gelegt
dafür wie wir mit russland umgehen
wollen um mit dem und beziehungen zu
russland es liegt noch sehr viel arbeit
vor uns ich sage nicht dass da alles
geschafft ist aber wir haben schon eine
menge erreicht uns bevor ich jetzt ihre
fragen entgegen nehmen lassen sie mich
noch eine sache sagen leute schaut es
geht doch hier darum wie wir ab jetzt
weitermachen
ich habe ein großteil der
pressekonferenz mit präsident putin
gehört er hat ja auch gesagt es geht um
eine praktische klare nonsens
entscheidungen die getroffen werden muss
oder auch nicht und das werden wir in
den nächsten sechs monaten herausfinden
ob wir einen strategischen dialog
hinbekommen der funktioniert ob wir
wirklich mit allem umgehen können was
zum beispiel die freilassung von
häftlingen russland betrifft wir werden
herausfinden ob wir eine cyber
sicherheit vereinbaren finden die
ordnung in die sache hinein bringt denn
die länder die am ehesten dadurch
geschädigt werden wenn das nicht
funktioniert das sind die großmächte ich
sprach über die pipeline die durch einen
rentenvertrag in den usa angegriffen
wurde dann habe ich gesagt wie würden
sie sich fühlen wenn diese erpressung
software sich gegen die pipelines ihrer
ölfelder richten würde das wäre von
bedeutung das wäre bedeutung für irland
es geht nicht nur um die eigenen
interessen
es geht um die gemeinsamen
eigeninteressen ich nehme gerne ihre
fragen entgegen
und ich habe hier auch eine liste von
leuten die sich gemeldet haben
danke der us geheimnis hat gesagt dass
usa bei dass die russlands bei den usa
wahlen sich eingemischt hat sie haben
die renz attacken erwähnt putin hat
gesagt wir übernehmen keine
verantwortung was da passiert ist
ihr vorgänger hat sich nicht dafür
entschieden zu fordern dass das
eingestellt was haben sie denn heute
erreicht dass so etwas nicht mehr
passiert und welche konsequenzen haben
die angedroht ob ich geschafft habe dass
das nicht wieder passiert weiß ich nicht
aber er weiß dass wir aktiv werden wie
wir es auch beim letzten mal gemacht
haben da haben wir auch deutlich gemacht
dass wir nicht zu sehen dass das so
weitergeht das ergebnis war dass wir die
botschafter zurückgezogen haben dass wir
bestimmte einrichtungen den usa
geschlossen haben
er weiß was die konsequenzen sind eine
der konsequenzen
naja vielleicht ist er vielleicht nicht
aber sie denken vielleicht dass es nicht
von bedeutung ist aber vertrauen
bedeutet ihm etwas und bedeutet uns
etwas seine vertrauenswürdigkeit
weltweit die sinkt die schrumpft wie
würden die vereinigten staaten denn vom
rest der welt angesehen werden wenn sie
sich direkt einmischen würden in die
wahlen eines anderen landes jeder weiß
das wie wäre es wenn wir aktivitäten
betreiben würden wie erste getrieben hat
das vermindert das ansehen eines landes
und er versucht natürlich verzweifelt
sein standing sein ansehen als großmacht
als führer einer großmacht zu schützen
und zu verteidigen
die maßnahmen die andere in diesem land
durchgeführt haben das ist für russland
der preis den sie zahlen und sie sind
nicht in der lage zu diktieren was in
der welt passiert
es sind andere länder die vereinigten
staaten unter anderem die da
konsequenzen an
herr präsident sie haben gesagt sie
haben mit ihm sehr viel über die
menschenrechte gesprochen
was würde denn passieren wenn der
opposition für alexei navalny stirbt ich
habe ihm deutlich gemacht dass ich
glaube die konsequenzen wären verheerend
für russland ich komme zurück zum selben
punkt was meinen sie
passiert wenn er sagt es geht ja gar
nicht um
alexej nawalny er hat natürlich da
vieles rational tsunami-wellen gesagt
aber was passiert dann wenn er im
gefängnis stirbt da habe ich zu ihm
gesagt das ist schon sehr von bedeutung
für ein land und da fragte mich warum
ich denn meine dass es wichtig ist dass
man weiterhin der präsident in syrien
kritisch sieht ja wegen der verstöße
gegen die chemiewaffen vertrag und
deshalb kann man ihm nicht trauen es
geht um das vertrauen in den einfluss
anderer länder gehen positive art und
weise würden sie unsere wirtschaft gegen
die russiche eintauschen wollen
dre und wir haben über den handel
gesprochen ich habe überhaupt kein
problem mit russland geschäfte zu machen
wenn das den internationalen normen
entspricht
es ist ja auch in unserem interesse dass
der russischen menschen wirtschaftlich
gut geht
aber wenn sie sich nicht an die
internationalen normen halten dann
passiert das nicht mit uns und nicht mit
anderen nation und darüber hat er ja
ausgesprochen darüber dass andere länder
ja in russland auch investieren sollen
das werden sie nicht tun
es sei denn sie können sich davon
überzeugen dass die verstöße die
begangen werden ein amerikanischer
geschäftsmann steht unter hausarrest und
wenn sie wollen dass amerikaner
investieren und geschäfte mit ihrem mann
dann müssen sie den mann frei lassen
das ist die dynamik als amerikanischer
geschäftsmann wird nicht nach moskau
reisen
wenn ihm das droht wir machen ja
außenpolitik auch mit dieser jahr mit
dieser eigenschaft dass man und nach
einen gewissen geheimen code arbeitet
weil es da sehr viel um persönliche
beziehungen gibt so funktioniert der
mensch von natur aus und wenn man ein
land führt
das sich nicht an die internationalen
normen hält man diese normen aber
braucht um das managen zu können und
auch die vor und nachteile
das ist keine zufriedenstellende antwort
dass er sagt da wurde russland ja da gab
es ja eine invasion das hat er nicht
ernst gemeint das war ein scherz aber es
macht die dinge komplizierter derby
zweier hat eine frage angemeldet im
vorfeld und dieses gesprächs wurde ja
viel gesprochen darüber dass die beiden
länder in einen kalten krieg wieder
abgleiten könnten und gibt es denn was
in diesen gesprächen entschuldigen wir
nicht das jackett aus es ist sehr heiß
gibt es irgendetwas was sie zu der
einschätzung führt dass präsident putin
von dieser rolle als störenfried
störenfried auch in bezug auf die nato
die vereinigten staaten sich entfernen
möchte und sie haben ihm die liste
gegeben die in der kritischen
infrastruktur in den usa haben sie
gesagt haben sie auch gesagt was die
strafe sein würde wenn er sich da
einmischt oder wie hat er darauf
reagiert ich darf die zweite frage
zuerst beantworten
ich habe deutlich gemacht dass wir
signifikante cyber fähigkeiten haben das
weiß er
er weiß nicht genau was es ist aber weiß
dass es signifikant ist und wenn sie die
und normen verletzen dann reagieren wir
in der cyberwelt und zum 2
das letzte was er jetzt sich wünschen
kann ist ein kalter krieg ich darf
vielleicht eine rhetorische frage
stellen sie haben einen mehr 1000 meilen
lange
grenze zu china und china versucht die
größte stärkste wirtschaft in der welt
zu werden und auch die starts der
militärmacht in der welt und dann kommt
man plötzlich in eine situation wo die
wirtschaft probleme hat und da muss man
natürlich darauf reagieren indem man sie
zu einem noch aggressiveren wachstum
führen und ich glaube nicht dass er an
einem kalten krieg mit den vereinigen
staaten interessiert ist
ich habe ihm auch gesagt ihre generation
im meine dies ist etwa zehn jahre
auseinander
das ist nicht für meine 60er jahren
sagte eine situation wo man sich in die
arme fällt aber es ist sicherlich nicht
in ihrem interesse indem ihres landes
und unseres dass wir wieder in einen
neuen kalten krieg geraten
und ich glaube dass er das auch so sieht
und versteht das bedeutet aber nicht
dass er jetzt einfach die waffen
niederlegt und sagt komm
nein ich denke er ist immer noch besorgt
dass wir möglicherweise niederringen
könnten er hat immer noch diese
besorgnis und ängste aber ich glaube
nicht dass das die treibende kraft ist
die hinter dem bemühen um das verhältnis
zu den usa steht jennifer jacobs bitte
gibt es einen bestimmten grund warum
dieser gipfel jetzt im grunde etwas mehr
als drei stunden gedauert hat obwohl er
zuerst von 45 stunden die rede war und
präsenten sagte es gab keine bedrohungen
oder androhungen das
dann in entsprechende taktische an
drogen nicht gegeben hat und auch
afghanistan wäre da ein thema zum ersten
teil zuerst das hat nicht länger
geschaut wann war denn das letzte mal
dass zwei staatslenker mehr als zwei
stunden über den tisch hinweg
miteinander gesprochen haben und auch
viele dinge im detail angesprochen haben
ich kann mich an keinen erinnern
im verlauf als wir dann eine größere
gruppe gewählt haben mit den
außenminister der dabei war und den
vertretern des militärs die botschafter
diplomaten in dieser größeren gruppe
hatten wir so viele themen schon
behandelt so dass wir mehr und ich dann
im grunde zusammengefasst haben
lepperhoff und linken haben auch über
das gesprochen und wir haben dann die
punkte aufgegriffen wo wir uns klar das
ist da keine missverständnisse mehr gab
und deshalb hatten wir nach diesen zwei
stunden die situation wir uns angeschaut
haben gesagt haben okay was kommt jetzt
als nächstes was passiert als nächstes
und wenn man nach vorn schaut und in 36
monaten dann überprüft auch das worüber
wir gesprochen haben auch jetzt so
funktioniert oder sind wir näher dran an
einen umfassenderen strategischen dialog
und an fortschritten sind wir weiter
gekommen auf dem richtigen weg das ist
ein test
ich stelle mich ja nicht hierher und
sage der präsenz und ich haben
vereinbart wird tun dass und plötzlich
von hier auf jetzt funktioniert das
alles so das sage ich ja nicht ich sage
es gibt die echte aussicht darauf dass
die beziehung zwischen den beiden länder
und signifikant verbessern ohne dass wir
nicht von unseren prinzipien und werten
aufgeben nicht ein jota nein es gab
keine androhung oder bedrohungen
ich glaube er hat auch zitiert dass ich
meine mutter erwähnte und ich habe
teilweise auch umgangssprachlich
formulierungen benutzen
über grundlegende dinge gesprochen ich
erkläre die dinge ja immer gern in bezug
auf persönliche beziehung was passiert
wenn das und das kommt und es gab keine
drohung es wagen einfach grundannahmen
die angemacht worden wenn hier das macht
machen wir das ich habe ihn wissen
lassen wo ich stehe
was ich denke dass wir gemeinsam
erreichen können und wenn es verstöße
gegen die amerikanische souveränität
gibt was wir dann tut werden
er fragte nach afghanistan und sagte er
hoffe dass wir in der lage sind frieden
und sicherheit aufrechtzuerhalten habe
ich gerade das hat auch viel mit ihnen
zu tun und er sagt er ist bereit
zitat zu helfen bei afghanistan und auch
zu helfen beim iran und wir haben dann
auch gesagt was wir tun wollen um
stabilität zu bringen und auch
wirtschaftliche sicherheit physische
sicherheit für die menschen auch in
syrien und in libyen dieses gespräch
haben wir auch geführt vielen dank herr
präsident
es gab keine an drogen aber gab es denn
ultimaten im bezug auf ransomware
attacken speziell auch zum thema
cybersicherheit das ist ganz einfach bei
der cyber sicherheit da werden wir
schauen welche maßnahmen sie dort gegen
präsent kriminelle auf dem russischen
territorium ergreifen werden sie haben
es noch nicht getan ich glaube sie haben
es geplant aber ob sie handeln werden
werden wir herausfinden
wir können uns verpflichten dass wir
bestimmte dinge unternehmen wenn
internationale
man verletzt werden und da haben wir
zugestimmt wir haben da echte
möglichkeiten uns weiter zu bewegen und
etwas das ich im größeren kreis
festgestellt habe ist dass menschen die
sehr sehr gut im fond informiert sind
sagen na ja das kann wirklich zu einem
echten problem werden wenn diese
erpressung software dann passiert und
wirklich auch lebensnotwendige systeme
bedroht das kann ja verheerend sein und
wir sehen ja was da passieren kann und
es ist deshalb in jedermanns interesse
dass man da handelt wir haben ja auch
gesehen was es bewirkt wenn wir solche
arbeitsgruppen dann schaffen herr
präsident
als präsident putin heute nach dem
menschenrecht nie gefragt wurde
da sagt er der grund warum er gegen die
oppositionsführer vorgehen er wollte
dass so etwas wie der sechste januar
nicht passiert in russland oder so etwas
wie die folgen von blackwater was sagen
sie dazu
ja meine antwort ist das was ich
kommuniziert habe ich denke das ist ein
lächerlicher vergleich das eine ist wenn
kriminelle wirklich den angriff auf das
kapital staaten einbrechen und beamte
töten oder es ist etwas anderes ob man
vor dem kapital des capitol protestiert
und sagt ihr erlaubt mir nicht zwei zu
sprechen das sind wirklich ganz
unterschiedliche kriterien zufrieden mit
ihrem kommentar dazu dass sie gesagt
haben er sei ein killer
was haben sie ihm gesagt er ist
zufrieden hat er gesagt wie soll ich das
thema dann warum soll ich das thema noch
einmal auf den tisch bringen wir meinen
sie
man kann den vertrauen nein da geht es
jetzt nicht um vertrauen sondern um
eigeninteressen und die überprüfung der
eigenen interessen
darum geht es ja jeder mit dem ich eine
vereinbarung treffen würde ich gegen die
amerikanischen interessen vertreten dann
würde ich doch nicht sagen
ich vertraue ihm kein problem also das
ist immer dass man es erst weiß wenn er
es denn passiert ist welche liberty
als nächstes möchten sie in den schatten
können sie mich überhaupt sehen von dort
gegen die sonne
[Musik]
die cyber-attacken die cyber-sicherheit
das thema in russland radio free europe
radio liberty weise vermerk america
dieses thema ausländische agenten da
sind die auch andere ausländische medien
betroffen wir wurden aus russland ja
vertrieben jahre nachdem wir dorthin
eingeladen wurden meine frage ist wie
interessiert ist präsident putin ihrer
meinung nach daran das klima die medien
betreffen zu verbessern in russland na
ja ich würde es nicht so nennen das
klima zu verbessern
geht es um die frage welches interesse
hatte ich eher daran russlands
reputation aufzupolieren
wenn er gegen demokratische prinzipien
freie meinungsäußerung
verstößt ich weiß es nicht ich kann das
nicht sagen
ich denke er ist daran interessiert die
nation so zu ändern dass maßnahmen von
denen er denkt dass sie das recht der
regierung zu tun was sie tut kritisieren
einschränkt das ist ein ganz anderer
ansatz
es gibt von denen ich habe fast alles
gelesen was er geschrieben hat die reden
die er gehalten hat ich habe auch eine
reihe von sehr guten biografie gelesen
die sie ja auch kennen und ich denke ich
habe aber auch deutlich gemacht dass
russland die gelegenheit hatte in
einigen momenten zu glänzen so ära
gorbatschow wo es auch in richtung einer
demokratischen regierung ging was dann
aber schief gegangen ist ist dass es ein
rennen unter den russischen
intellektuellen gab in der frage wie man
die russische regierung haben möchte und
wie man sie wählt und präsident putin
hat sich dafür entschieden dass russland
russland ist ja immer schon eine
großmacht gewesen
da ging es ja nicht nur um die
ideologien ob es dann in der zarenzeit
war oder in der russischen revolution
oder darum wo russland heute steht
ich denke mir ist das klar und ich habe
das gesagt und er hat auch entschieden
dass russland als großmacht bestehen
kann weiter ist dass man das russische
volk vereint auf die stärke der
regierung die kontrolle der regierung
nicht ideologisch sondern auf das
regieren bezogen und das ist die
entscheidung die von ihm getroffen wurde
ich werde da jetzt nicht herum rätseln
ob das auch fundamental anders
werden können aber da geht es russland
darum selbst als eine der großmächte der
welt weiter bestand zu haben
das militär reaktionen bezug auf die
roten linie die sie erwähnt haben
militärische reaktionen als antworten
auf erpressung attacken kam das zur
sprache und präsentation hat sie einen
erfahrenen mann genannt und sie haben
ihm ja mal gesagt er habe keine seele
verstehen sie denn jetzt nach diesem
treffen besser vielen dank vielen dank
nein über militärische reaktionen haben
wir nicht gesprochen
sie haben gibt keinen ersatz für einen
dialog von mann zu mann und das die
größten probleme im moment wenn die nato
russland und china sind sie haben ja
vielfach darüber gesprochen dass sie mit
präsident schien weise mehr zeit
verbracht haben im gespräch als andere
führungspersönlichkeiten der welt
könnten zeitpunkt geben wo sie ihn
sozusagen unter freunden anrufen und
fragen wie china da zum beispiel
international helfen kann auch in bezug
auf corona und das klarzustellen wir
sind nicht alte freunde
da geht es nur um reines business e
rockit das ist meine frage sie haben ja
das g7 communiqué mit unterzeichnet dass
man china dazu aufruft sich zu öffnen
und china hat gesagt sie möchten da
nicht sich einmischen was passiert nun
ja die haltung der welt richtung china
die entwickelt sich ja auch china
versucht ja sehr stark sich als
verantwortlich darzustellen als eine
nation auf dem vormarsch
und die kämpfen ja auch sehr hart darum
wie sie der welt gegen korona helfen
können auch mit vakzinen manche dinge
muss man aber erst mal den menschen in
der welt erklären und man sieht die
ergebnisse ist china da tatsächlich
aktiv und die g7 die nato was wir tun
sollten ist dass wir die welt versammeln
um die frage wie der mechanismus sein
kann dass wir die nächste pandemie
frühzeitig erkennen und dass wir einen
mechanismus haben wie wir darauf
reagieren können und frühzeitig
reagieren können das wird passieren und
das müssen wir tun
vielen dank und dann geht es der us
präsident in den schatten das war seine
pressekonferenz und seine antworten auf
die fragen der journalisten seiner
einschätzung des gipfels mit dem
russischen präsidenten putin
wir wollen über das was jetzt joe biden
gesagt hat sprechen mit unserem usa
korrespondenten elmar theveßen der beide
pressekonferenzen verfolgt hat und immer
noch ist vor dem ort des gipfeltreffens
der villa orange immer wie ist diese
pressekonferenz wie ist das was beiden
gesagt hat einzuordnen der doch sehr
klar auch gesagt hat ich habe präsident
putin gesagt was ich sagen wollte
ja ich glaube es ist ein gemischtes
ergebnis von dieser pressekonferenz des
präsidenten einerseits wirkt er stark
wenn er im grunde genommen sagt es geht
ja nicht um vertrauen zwischen uns es
geht darum dass es um selbst interesse
um eigeninteresse der jeweiligen staaten
geht also der usa und russland und beide
starten so sagt beiden eben in der
pressekonferenz haben kein interesse
daran wieder in einen kalten krieg
zurückzufallen und deswegen kommt es
darauf an das was man heute vereinbart
hat und der präsident der usa ist der
meinung das sind schon konkrete punkte
in einigen monaten wieder zu überprüfen
also wirklich de facto zu überprüfen ob
man ein stück weit vorangekommen ist ob
russland tatsächlich signalisiert und
zeigt dass man ja mit ihm im grunde
genommen vereinbarungen treffen kann und
dann noch fortschritte erzielt das ist
der teil
ich glaube da kommt der relativ stark
rüber aber er muss natürlich dann auch
in drei monaten zeigen ob es was
gebracht hat unterstrich die
pressekonferenz war teilweise aber auch
ein ich sag mal großer moment der
schwäche von joe biden
gerade in bezug auf die menschenrechte
oder in bezug auf das verhalten
russlands bei der verletzung
internationaler normen
sich hinzustellen und zu sagen ich habe
ihn mal sehr klar gemacht warum wir als
amerikaner das so sagen müssen weil wir
amerikaner weil amerika hat bestimmte
werte hat und diese werte bedeuten dass
man diese sachen ansprechen muss dass
man hat das aussprechen muss dass man
diese vorwürfe machen muss aber das
dürfte wladimir putin wenig
beeindruckend ist hatte ihn auch wenig
beeindruckt das haben wir ja vorhin in
der pressekonferenz gesehen
denn wenn ein präsident einfach nur sagt
ich muss erklären warum wir das so sagen
dann ist das ein stück weit
möglicherweise auch ein signal an einen
autoritären machthaber dass er sagte ok
das verstehe ich ja wenn ihr euch dann
immer öffentlich darüber beschweren muss
aber es ist unterm strich meine sache
und deswegen glaube ich da hat der
amerikanische präsident vor hin
ich glaube ein sehr schwachen auftritt
in dieser pressekonferenz hingelegt ja
immer das ist die frage wie ist das
alles zu bewerten
ich habe zumindest den eindruck gehabt
dass beiden doch versucht hat zumindest
stark zu wirken indem er gesagt hat ich
habe gesagt was ich sagen wollte und
dass er dann doch sehr schnell diese
ganzen punkte menschenrechte
cyberattacke syrien iran markt das
ukraine belarus etc
er wollte doch wohl deutlich machen dass
er alle themen angesprochen hatte um
sozusagen der kritik zu entgehen das
thema hast du vergessen aber die frage
ist natürlich alle themen ansprechen ist
das eine aber wo hat man was irgendwie
erreicht ja ich glaube man muss noch mal
klar machen es war auch nicht zu
erwarten im vorfeld das nur weil die
beiden sich jetzt treffen und weil joe
biden sagt nach nach westlichen werten
ist dass ein regelverstoß und deswegen
akzeptieren wir das nicht dass der
russische präsident dann einfach
einlenkt und sagt ja wir lassen herren
aber nie frei und lassen kümmern uns
auch wieder intensiver um die
menschenrechte in russland
das war eigentlich auch gar nicht zu
erwarten ich glaube zählbarer und
wichtiger ist das was eben am konkreten
dingen vereinbart worden ist der
russische präsident in einem autoritären
regime wird sich am ende ja nicht um 180
grad drehen und eigentlich war es auch
ein stücklein oder wäre es ein stück
weit naiv zu erwarten dass auf einmal
alles besser wird der us-präsident hat
ja auch gesagt und sehr klar gemacht
wenn beispielsweise weil neben gefängnis
sterben würde ja dann würde das eben
russland auf die füße fallen weil man
die qualität eines anführers auch eines
anführers wie wladimir putin danach
beurteilt wie er mit den menschen in
seinem land umgeht das ist eigentlich
nur ein indirekter nachteil dass es
keine sanktionen er hat nicht gedroht
mit sanktionen er wurde ja auch gefragt
ob die usa ob der präsident irgend ein
ultimatum gestellt hätten in irgendeinem
punkt nein das hat er nicht er will erst
einmal erkunden wo kann man vielleicht
zusammenarbeiten und möglicherweise im
zuge dieser zusammenarbeit dann auch die
lebenssituation der menschen ein stück
weit verbessern das ist im grunde
genommen am ende ja manche werden ist
als kapitulation bezeichnen ich kann mir
die schlagzeilen schon vorstellen
andererseits ist es auch realpolitik
weil man genau weiß wenn man nicht einen
krieg anfangen will einen großen
konflikt wird man die hebel auch nicht
in der hand haben um wladimir putin zu
einer änderung seines verhaltens zu
bewegen ist dann in der linie elmar
sozusagen auch zu sehen
eine formulierung von beiden es gibt
keinen ersatz für den direkten dialog
und es haben zwei menschen miteinander
gesprochen die verantwortung tragen für
die beziehung zwischen zwei und dann
sagte biden zwei stolzen großen ländern
ist das auch so ein bisschen balsam auf
die russische seele damit das eis ein
bisschen schmilzt und man überhaupt mal
irgendwie weiterkommt denn das war ja
nun gerade wir haben es
sendung früher ja schon gesprochen eben
ein harter ein harter begriff als obama
von einer regionalmacht sprach und eben
russland meinte das ist ja ein stachel
sozusagen im fleisch der russischen
seele ist das so dass beiden vielleicht
geschickt versuchte mit solchen
formulierungen dann sozusagen auch für
die nächsten treffen für die nächsten
verhandlungen dann weiter zu kommen ja
ich glaube das ist so man sagt ja so
dass man zu solchen verhandlungen auch
wenn es harte verhandlungen sein soll
immer zuckerbrot und peitsche mitbringen
sollte man muss was anzubieten haben
aber man muss auch ein druckmittel in
der hand haben in diesem fall scheint
heute das zuckerbrot ein stück überwogen
zu haben
er hat tatsächlich den stolz von
wladimir putin ein stück weit ja
angesprochen und putin hat das genauso
auch verstanden er hat ja in seiner
pressekonferenz gesagt also dass sich
ein amerikanischer präsident fast zwei
stunden zeit nimmt für einen anführer
der sei ja doch ein zeichen wie wichtig
das alles mit anderen worten wie wichtig
er am ende ist ich glaube schon dass er
da pluspunkte mit nach hause nimmt
in der innenpolitik russlands
gleichzeitig aber vielleicht und das ist
die hoffnung der amerikaner ein
stückweit bereiter ist auch ins
nachdenken zu kommen ob das klappt ob
ein machtmensch wie putin auch beiden
ist ein machtmensch aber auch so einer
der machtpolitik im grunde genommen auch
braucht um macht zu erhalten
ob so einer willens ist seine ansichten
zu verändern nur weil die beiden sagt
überlegt doch mal es gibt da eine
hunderte von kilometer lange grenze
tausende von kilometer lange grenze
zwischen russland und china auch
russland muss ein interesse daran haben
dass man mit china in zukunft fertig
wird dass man die große herausforderung
möglicherweise auch die gegnerschaft
chinas ernst nimmt er appelliert also
ein stück weit an die vernunft aber ob
das wirklich ankommt das kann man
wirklich nur sehen wenn in den nächsten
wochen und monaten zählbare erfolge
dabei rauskommen und man hat ja sich
klar vereinbart dass beispielsweise was
den strategischen
aber schwierigkeit ich wollte der
leistung eines präsidenten jetzt wenn
man sich ja immer so ja immer wir hören
dich nur die letzten 30 sekunden warst
du gerade da also na ja vielleicht weil
der us-präsident uns ein stück weit mit
seinem störsender beeinträchtigt hat das
könnte gut sein
eine staatskarosse fährt hier gerade so
ist das und da ist auch die
entsprechenden fahrzeuge funktechnik mit
dabei also ich glaube dass der
amerikanische präsident nach hause fährt
nach einer erfolgreichen woche hat es
geschafft bei den verschiedenen
gipfeltreffen doch verbündete hinter
sich zu bringen und für die westlichen
werte zu werben
aber ob zählbares dabei heraus kommt in
den nächsten wochen und monaten zum
beispiel neben der strategischen dialog
über die atomwaffen mit russland das
werden wir in drei monaten so sagt der
präsident einmal genau betrachten und
beurteilen können
joe biden fliegt jetzt nach hause schon
wahrscheinlich in wenigen stunden hier
aus genf zurück in die usa
und dann geht die arbeit los nämlich auf
diplomatischer ebene tatsächlich das was
heute besprochen wurde in handfeste
ergebnisse umzusetzen
ein user david schmidt schreibt über
youtube ja dieses treffen hat die lage
vielleicht definitiv entschärft man
kommuniziert wieder miteinander ein
erster schritt so ungefähr deutet du das
an elmar und beiden selbst hat ja gesagt
es besteht eine echte aussicht und
aussicht heißt ja der blick nach vorne
dass sich die beziehungen verbessern
aber ohne dass eine seite seinen
standpunkt irgendwie aufgeben muss und
kann also zeigt dass auch so ein
bisschen respekt und ja die aussicht ist
daneben bedeutet auch der blick in die
zukunft man wird es dann überprüfen
müssen
emma vielen vielen dank für die
einschätzungen und sehr interessant zu
sehen was es bedeutet wenn ein
amerikanischer präsident an einem
aufsager platz vorbei fährt er immer
vielen vielen dank grüße nach genf
ja und das war unser zdf livestream zu
dem ersten gipfel von us-präsident
beiden mit dem russischen präsidenten
putin in genf wir haben ausführlich und
komplett bei der pressekonferenzen
zuerst die vom russischen präsidenten
und jetzt gerade von us-präsident beiden
gehört ja man kann gespannt sein wie die
entwicklung weitergehen wird beide
experten haben es angedeutet
es kann jetzt noch keine festen
ergebnisse geben aber ein beginn für
gespräche ist gemacht und wir werden
weiter sehen was dieser erste gipfel am
ende für auswirkungen hat vielen dank
für ihr interesse und einen schönen
namen doch